china
is taking covet very seriously
and many of us been wondering how is it
that their numbers have been so low this
whole time
europe have has been devastated the
riots in europe and the netherlands
particularly are so bad
that one mayor is saying it's like civil
war or or i'm sorry that
we're on the verge of civil war over the
covet restriction
lockdowns in the us we've seen
widespread riots and anger
well i would say the riots have been
primarily fueled by other things but
definitely
many people have said that being pent up
over the lockdowns and restrictions has
made people kind of angry and go nuts
and there's been
a lot of riots because of it but in
europe we've seen a lot in tunisia we've
seen over 600 people arrested
and the question is once again how has
china managed to keep
everything so tame well simple
better testing donald trump should have
figured this out
with better testing we know exactly how
many people have cove and how to
restrict them
and it was simple china's been anal
swabbing
everybody to get a better reading i'm
not kidding
it's an actual story from newsweek china
has been anal
anal swabbing their citizens because
they say it's a better test
and i'm sorry luke he brought this up to
me and i said that's not true
i literally ran in the house i was like
i told you so it's coming it was here if
you remember a couple days ago i was
here i was like what's next they're
going to literally
start shoving things up of your buttocks
i said this on the show i said this for
years i ran inside after i saw this
newsweek article
and i was like it's here it's finally
here it was coming today
he was like it's happening like i told
you and and it's not probing
it it's not sorry it's it's what what
was the term that they used
anal swab no it's anal probing
since it goes in two inches and then
they're inside and then they say they
rotate it yes and i'm sorry i'm sorry
someone made a very inappropriate joke
saying two inches that's a lot in asia
i'm not going to say who said that
but but it's not it's it's not swabbing
okay
probing the point is i when when i heard
this i started laughing cause i'm like
it kind of just sounds like they're
pushing our butt to see how much we're
willing to accept before we finally lose
our minds
but apparently in china everybody's okay
with it is it forced anal swabbing
in china everything's forced okay they
have a social credit score you sneezed
the wrong way your credit is going to go
down
and you can't even go see a movie
anymore that's going to be shut down
you've got to get tested
in order to go in buildings you get a
phone with a bar code
and so if you want to get your test and
the only thing they're doing is shoving
stuff up people's butts guess what it's
either that or nothing
so welcome to the brave new world
china's doing it look but china also
welded people into their homes and stuff
like that so
i don't know what america would would be
willing to accept with this
but uh dr fauci says hey two masks
oh my god why didn't we realize this if
you wear one mask
just wear two and then i'm kind of like
well
dr fauci should what about three oh
that's makes i'm not kidding dr fauci is
not saying we should wear two masks
okay sure whatever i swear they're just
pushing buttons and laughing like to
figure out how much we're gonna take
before we finally snap
and things are good i think if they
start anal probing people here they're
gonna go crazy
no i don't you don't think so don't
think so what if it's forced though
that's what i'm concerned about
is that they're holding them down and
they were like they're already saying
that your kids can't go to their
mouth is no good i mean some people
might lose it
but they're already saying like you kids
can't go to school you can't go on
planes
unless you get your vaccine you it
united airlines said all their employees
have to get vaccinated now if they want
to work there
and people are just like all right you
know look i i i got no problem with
vaccines be completely honest i just
don't like the idea of forced anything
so if people are gonna get some invasive
forced medication or whatever then i
think if they're willing to accept
that come on man the vaccine goes in you
it's there forever and if you've got no
problem with that then do you think
people are really going to complain
about having a swab shoved up their butt
some people might some people are
complaining about the vaccine i'm just
saying it's crazy okay anyway there's a
bunch of other stories because
we got in uh in you know like i
mentioned in the netherlands there's
mass riot so we'll talk about this
we've got uh the fbi is now saying
they're going to actually be charging
people with sedition
xi jinping was the talk of the town over
at davos liberals are all clapping and
cheering for that guy
and uh this is interesting the oregon
republican party says the capital was a
false flag which is a bold statement the
media is already screaming about
so we'll get to all this stuff and then
um maybe we'll get to this we
there's like a lost um a lost what is it
native american or whatever
indigenous fortress to fight the
russians found and i think it'd be fun
to talk about some weird and wild stuff
so
we'll get into that ladies and gentlemen
that was a long intro and i gotta
introduce we have a great guest we have
alex holliday of control
pew what you do something you do a thing
tell me what that thing is alex yeah so
i'm part of a community that
design and 3d print firearms and we
release them
to the internet uh for free and
uh people can make them at home you're
teaching you're giving people designs to
make guns at home yes
is that legal yes wow so in most places
and federally speaking it is entirely
legal to manufacture your own firearms
at home for personal use
we were talking about this a couple
episodes ago
and we were talking about the liberator
mm-hmm and i was like doesn't it isn't
the 3d gun like it fires once and like
it breaks or something and then people
in the chat were like dude you are so
far behind on the current tech and i was
like well i don't know
and so we got someone who doesn't know
there you go he's chilling and so we'll
definitely talk about that stuff for
sure
of course we got luke talking about anal
swabs he's here i've been warning about
anal swabs and probings for 15 years i'm
an independent journalist old man that's
been doing work on the youtube channel
we are changed uh check me out there if
you want to see
years of warning you that the anal
probes
are are coming they're here in china and
uh it's only going to it's only going to
get worse
the ian's challenge the anal prophecy
has come true
um alex what's the best 3d printer or
printers to get to make guns
uh if you're on a tight budget if you
only have you know you can get in for
200 bucks
if that's all you've got to spend get an
ender 3 pro
i mean get them off amazon takes like
three days to your door cool
and you're basically set uh if you've
got a little more money to spend
go for an ender 5 pro uh it's a little
more robust of a machine
get you a little further but they're
still they're basically the same machine
it's just like a little bit
abs like plastic printing yeah exactly
but you need to still need metal parts
don't you yeah in
in all of the designs we have now are
require some metal parts like a bolt or
a barrel
um but we've also figured out how to
easily manufacture these
with off common you know off-the-shelf
parts you can order mail order from
china
um so it's it's really like we've solved
all the big problems
to get to the gun and you're you're
talking about something i don't know if
it's a top secret project
your secret secret weapon it's it's a
little secret we've we've it's been
talked about
uh a little bit in the in the back
channels we'll we'll we'll save the
secret talk for later once we get to the
nitty nitty-gritty don't forget sour
patch let's see here she's pushing
around the corner i'm just thinking
about colonoscopies as we're talking
about probing people so i don't know
if there's any overlap but people will
do whatever you tell them to do if they
think it's necessary
before we get into all the news make
sure you go to timcast.com and become a
member ladies and gentlemen we got top
secret posts actually it's not secrets
members only posts and we made sure to
put the members at tim cast email to
make sure everybody
get you know gets through that error we
did a segment recently about the
portland mayor pepper spraying some dude
we kind of just ragged on him for quite
a bit and
all that stuff but once i got another
video of alex jones waking up luke oh
i'm definitely going to milk that for
all it's worth
[Laughter]
it's funny it's not political it's not
news it's literally just watching
some silliness i'm still taking
suggestions on who i should surprise tim
poole with when he's sleeping so feel
free to message me that
on my uh twitter account lukeware change
become a member help support the show
because we're gonna be expanding the
members only content of course this show
is always gonna be free and if you
really wanna make sure that
in the event we get banned we still
exist in some form this is the way to do
it
that being said my friends let's talk
about anal swabs
newsweek.com reports covered anal
swabs for beijing residents more
accurate says chinese expert
i'll tell you right away i'm not going
to bury the lead they've been doing this
for a long time now
so you know luke is talking about some
prophecy is actually already happening
check this out
they say more than a million beijing
residents undergoing coronavirus testing
amid a fresh outbreak
have been administered anal swabs which
are considered more accurate
and raise the chances of detecting
covid19 said a chinese disease
specialist i got to stop right there
okay you know i don't believe it the
swabbing in the nose makes sense because
it's a respiratory
disease how does it make sense that cove
was in your butt in the mucus
well yeah yeah cause like you cough it
up right well your butt has
mucus in it does that mean cove all
right
if you guys really want to get down with
it it coats the species
does that mean you fart covered yeah
most undoubtedly no i don't know about
that
i think there was an article i i don't
remember that i think lydia you remember
this
wasn't there an article that says that
you transmit covid through farts
you do and it can be an sti did you know
that yeah i keep telling you to stop
farting all over the place hey hey hey
we're gonna talk about that
all right they say the key districts of
daxing and dongcheng began a mass
testing drive on friday
after a nine-year-old boy tested
positive for the more virulent strain of
the virus
first discovered in london and the
southeast of england last month
health authorities in the chinese
capital said they were aiming to screen
more than 2 million people in 48 hours
among them
around 1.6 million inhabitants of daxing
were to be given antibody tests
as well as throat nasal and rectal
nucleic acid
swabs wonderful anal swabs have been in
use
since last year including in the major
port city of shanghai
but the methods is so far reserved for
individuals in potential covenanting hot
spots
according to an infectious disease
expert quoted by china state broadcaster
cctv
on saturday quote since the start of the
chronovirus outbreak
we've tested for the virus using mainly
throat swaps its characteristics are
convenience and speed
so it's suitable for large scale testing
said beijing yuan hospital's lee
tongzeng
nasal swabs are more accurate than
throat swabs but nasal swabs can be
uncomfortable
ah well there's a solution to that on
comfort discomfort
in some asymptomatic cases or in
individuals with mild symptoms they tend
to recover from the
illness very quickly it's possible that
there will be no trace of the virus in
their throat after three to five days
what we've found is that in some
infected patients the coronavirus
survives for a longer period of time in
their digestive tract
or excrement than in their respiratory
tract couldn't you just take a dump in a
in a cup and give them a cup and leave
yeah no they want to jam something up
your butt
it's got to be fresh
we're laughing at this it's like it's
like laughing as the titanic is sinking
do you have a picture of the swab by any
chance
we gotta throw it up on the screen i
posted about this story and everyone's
sending me very inappropriate pictures
of what allegedly is the
pictures of cuomo from cnn and other
items
that i can't describe here on this very
family-friendly show but but again the
medical experts here
are saying that this is going to help
the rate of
detectability and lower the chance of
mis uh
diagnosis so uh
[Music]
yes there's the article i have an image
uh i have an image of the swab here just
uh
yeah just to show everybody okay
now i
cnn is doing news and they're like look
at this prop comedy we're doing yeah
yeah yeah we get it well
but also most importantly the article
goes on and says on friday a resident of
tangzhan in hubei province about 120
miles east of beijing
told cctv that she was given double
rectal swabs probes they're really
probes because they go inside to two
inches inside of you
as part of a city-wide testing in her
area she said she
said each swab took just under 10
seconds so
you were talking about people being pent
up and they're definitely going to have
to loosen up with
all these new government testings and
you were you were questioning
is is it is it mandatory is it voluntary
in china nothing is voluntary if you
make fun of the government
government officials will literally take
you away take you away away at night
sit you down in a chair where you're
handcuffed with your feet and hands
and will interrogate you until you
apologize for making fun of the
government
if you're lucky otherwise a lot of
people just get their organs harvested
in china for criticizing the government
and and of course having things like
religion yeah having thing you know this
of course is not something there is that
it's going to be voluntary there's a
viral video of a dude in a chair
like yeah that's what he's talking about
and the cops are like so why did you say
you don't like police
and he's like i'm so it's all in
mandarin it's like i'm so sorry i didn't
mean it i was just drinking and they're
like you were drinking
you think that absolves your
responsibility you thought it was okay
to make fun of the police and he's
begging them i'm so sorry
it's a black room and he's he's bolted
down to a chair
as they're like threatening him and
demanding you apologize and say i'll
never do it again
there's another video where a woman
turns her phone camera on and puts it
down
you hear a knock on the door and then
cops come in and just randomly arrest
her and she's like what's happening and
they're like shut up you're under arrest
i think she was one of the people
warning the world about kovid
because a lot of nurses a lot of doctors
a lot of lawyers a lot of journalists
went to jail and are still missing
because they were
telling people of the world hey there's
this mystery
virus going around last year and then
the chinese government was hiding that
fact of course making sure the world was
unprepared
when they knew well there are some
reports and intelligence from november
that the chinese government knew that
there was this new strain of
coronavirus that was going around that
they knew was going to be a major they
instructed
chinese nationals in other countries to
start collecting
ppe buying it up and sending it back to
china
so that they would have it other
countries wouldn't
that's what they do you know i mean i
can't blame them for fighting for their
own personal interest or their own
national interests but i can't blame
them for the freaky authoritarianism and
all that stuff
now listen here in the united states we
don't have these anal probe things going
on
yeah yes uh considering xi jinping was a
talk of the town over at davos i
wouldn't be surprised if they come back
and they're like you're not a bigot are
you stop being
prude and accept your probe okay well we
don't have that going on for now but we
do have fauci saying
two masks why didn't anybody think of
this we were all wearing one mask
to stop the spit from coming out now
fauci is talking about two masks
perhaps he's talking about wearing a
mask on your butt to stop the butt
covered from coming out but he's not
he's talking about wearing two masks on
your face
the new york post says two face masks
are better than one
dr factor said monday the infectious
disease specialist advised that double
masking is a logical way to curb the
spread of the coronavirus
if you have a physical covering with one
layer you put another layer on
it just makes common sense that it
likely would be more effective fauci
said on the today show
the white house advisor explained that
face coverings prevent respiratory
droplets
and the virus from spreading to other
people as well as protecting the wearer
oh now they're saying it protects you
[Music]
he's saying it would likely be better so
he's not saying it doesn't know he
doesn't know
yeah well this is also the same guy that
just a few months ago was telling us
not to wear masks it's not safe you
don't know what you're doing especially
if you're not a medical professional
stop buying and using all the masks and
you know what's the point if someone
farts and toots anyway you're going to
get kovitz so
what's the point of having a mask well
more specifically is
his tone so this was this was last year
when
a bunch of conservatives were like go
quick go buy masks and the media was
like oh geez don't buy masks
and the chinese government was buying up
right a lot of the mouse fauci's
attitude wasn't just
well you don't need to buy masks and
here's why it was really condescending
it was like oh you don't need masks oh
come on what's up a mascot's gonna
protect you don't bother
and then we even had the surgeon general
saying the same thing and then sure
enough something weird happened where
like conservatives in the left flipped
on the issue
and then all of a sudden conservatives
are the ones not wearing masks and the
left were the ones wearing masks
i have no idea how that happened but
there you go probably because fauci said
it i guess and then trump didn't wear a
mask and then
there you go look i see this story about
fauci
saying we should wear two masks and it's
i know it's not the same as
you know shoving stuff up you know
people's butts but it really does feel
like they're just pushing our buttons to
see
like how long until someone just finally
gives up and just like snaps goes crazy
well people in holland it looks like a
lot of them are snapping already
especially with a lot of the civil
unrest that's happening there
there's been a lot of protests all over
the world that have not been talked
about they're not getting a lot of media
coverage
it looks like you know the larger
algorithms aren't really even interested
in them
but it i think you know i agree somewhat
what your point there
but we have to understand a lot of these
so-called medical professionals a lot of
these experts they were wrong from the
from the very beginning whether it was
their projections whether it was their
recommendations
they were flat out wrong and they
haven't admitted
it they haven't had any accountability
they haven't faced any repercussions for
actions that did lead to some severe
ramifications that they should be held
responsible for
and unless that happens it's hard to
believe them from here
yeah in the beginning everyone believe
them that's my issue is you've got a lot
of people who don't trust the medical
professionals and like the experts on
covenant stuff
yet when you talk about how fauci was
wrong early on they say well science is
always wrong that's the beauty of
science you can get it wrong and you fix
it later and i'm like that's great
so you're admitting that there's reason
for people to doubt the scientists
because look
for the most part i think the only thing
a sane person can do is just follow the
standard guidance as
it is it's the best you can do there's
this movie i don't know if you guys have
ever seen it called the man from earth
you ever hear of it
it's about uh it's like it's like a
one-shot film where they're all in just
a room
and long story short it's this guy who
is immortal
and he tells all these stories about how
he's lived through all these different
periods
and they're like you must be the
smartest guy in the world and he's like
why i only know what everyone else knows
i don't listen
like know everything and a lot of the
old information is bad
and that's the way i see it like for me
look if they come out and they say wear
a mask i'll be like
what am i supposed to do pretend like
i'm smarter than these actors no i got
no problem wearing a mask
but come on come on when you come out
you're like now wear two masks it's like
i'm already wearing a mask dude like and
besides what mask are you talking about
like what if i'm wearing like a crazy
scarf wrapped all the way my face would
put something else over it
it's just a nonsensical statement we're
already wearing masks dude
yeah you would think they would talk
about vitamin d you would think they
would well he did
he did he did he found she's told people
to get vitamin d for sure um
okay that's that's a big surprise
because a lot of government officials
a lot of foreign policy hasn't even
addressed
that basic factor of health of sleep of
stress of diet of exercise of going out
there getting proper sun getting proper
vitamin d
and if he did mention it there's also a
lot of scientists screaming about this
from the very beginning since there are
results
showing that vitamin deficient people
have a horrible time dealing with this a
lot of people are extremely vitamin
deficient in vitamin d deficient
especially with all the lockdowns that
have
taken their ability of even going
outside you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to clean my mask when's the
last time you guys washed your mask
what do you mean washed what is that
what is it give it some soap rinse it
off
squeeze it out let it air dry huh
what a novel yeah time to wash your mask
folks
but that is something people bring up a
lot i was kidding by the way yeah that
people keep reusing the same mask and
they're getting
festering and filthy two times there are
videos of people getting like crud on
their mouths and stuff
like your mask i mean fouchy tell people
to wash their masks
a lot of people wear disposable ones to
be honest though that's true i guess
that's what he's saying like wear a
disposable one under your permanent one
oh that's specifically what he was
saying i don't know but it's like a
picture of people doing it
it's just the weird it's the weirdest
stock in the mask industry maybe
yeah yeah there you go in the uh chinese
manufacturing plants that produce
these goods the same maps protect you
from the virus that came out of china
yeah so i'm starting to think that they
told us not to wear masks at the
beginning so that china could buy all
our masks
up and we wouldn't be like getting in
their way and i'm curious why he doesn't
why he's telling people to wear a double
mask and why he's not telling them to
wear like the higher technology masks
that might actually protect you from the
virus or telling people not to fart
right exactly the joke now is that
fauci's eventually going to tell us all
to rap
was it babylon b i think fauci says
everyone should wrap themselves in
plastic to protect themselves
it's like a woman and she's like all
mashed up and tangled in plastic wrap
and can't move
i'm glad you said it because i was going
to make that joke
[Laughter]
i can see it coming i mean my joke was
that and i think i made this joke a year
ago
in like 2030 everyone will be wearing
gray jumpsuits with no pockets
and they'll have shaved heads and
they'll carry nothing on their person
they'll own nothing and they'll just
walk to and from like public transport
and work and
then i realized that although that would
probably be fairly extreme it's not
extreme enough for where we're ahead in
terms of critical race theory
people would have to be you you would
have this white
box over your body that you held so no
one would know how tall you were
and you'd have a voice modulator where
you would type inside your box and then
it would you do a computer voice
no one would know your gender no one
would know how tall you are nobody
would know your race nobody would know
what you sounded like and that's the
only way to ever actually achieve some
kind of equality
but then you have the problem of some
people just being naturally more
talented or faster
what do you do and then we get into that
we kept them no no it's that book
and bergeron bridger yeah where the
beautiful people have to like what do
they do they wear terrible makeup or
they like wear bags over the heads and
the really good people at dancing get
weighted down or they get their feet cut
off the smart people have things in
their ears that scream random sounds to
like
interrupt their thinking so they can't
be smart well they're already
starting to cut back on the gifted
programs in many public schools all over
the united states which
i find uh kind of crazy to do so
uh they're doing it because of uh
equality but but you're you're
preventing people from
getting a better education than they
normally would and you're holding people
back
because of other people not doing that
well i mean it just doesn't make any
logical systems you're saying you don't
believe in equality
oh no you don't you're you're saying i
don't you're saying that you're you're
you're
a bigot uh no i'm not saying that i'm
just saying a lot of people have gone
absolutely mad
with this idea that we're all supposed
to be equal when
when you look at nature i mean nothing's
equal in nature and it's all about
survival of the
fittest and i think we as humanity will
progress once we understand that and
and open ourselves up to that kind of
understanding uh which will help us move
forward in life more accurately and
correctly that's what something that
michael malus brought up
he said how you define the new right is
this let me ask you a question alex
do you think that some people are better
than others
yes that's the that's it yeah so he said
the right will tell you yes and the left
will give you an explanation
or like you know justify something and i
just said
my answer was like simply yes but it's
an interesting way to define it
and i see his point but i'm like i'm not
going to argue with you
it's a very simple statement some people
are better than others
now if you want to get into specifics
some people are better basketball than
others
very obvious but the left views it from
a very like
identitarian view like when you ask them
as some people better than others they
take it to a racial or
gender or like you know inherent
identity place
whereas my initial reaction was like
that's a very broad question that could
mean a bunch of different things
some people are better at printing guns
than i am and some people know a lot
more are better at me than answering gun
trivia than i
am yeah absolutely you know it reminds
me like when i was little
i was i would always hear like these
teenage girls use the word ignorant
they'd be like that's so ignorant you're
so ignorant and i'm like
do you know what ignorant means it means
like not understanding or like lacking
knowledge
and they're like no it means rude and
i'm like no it doesn't like i understand
the concept you think you're using your
con the context you think you're using
it in
but i was like everyone is ignorant in
some form and they get all angry about
it was it annoying when you were young
how like
the sometimes popular people would be
stupid and they
they'd say stupid stuff like that and
you'd be like
uh have to just deal with it because
they were like part of the gang
the popular gang of i mean they were
smart they were really dumb
unpopular kids too and they were i don't
know where i grew up it was kind of
amazing
so frustrating when the people that are
like lauded by the crowd are not
necessarily the smartest people
what are they allotted by the crowd for
because they're beautiful because
they're good at sport because they're
fast i don't know there you go
well not everybody then they'd say stuff
like ignorance means
but that that's stupidity but that's the
important point about the question are
some people
better than others you could be stupid
but strong as an ox
and then you have like right well some
people are better at
certain things than others but those
other people might be better at certain
things than them so to say that some
people are better than others
is not accurate i don't think it is i
think no it's situational
but like you might be better at shooting
guns but i might be better doing math
yeah
it doesn't mean that you're better than
me or i'm better than you yes it does
yeah you're
both better than each other so it's
redundant this is exactly the point i
was just making
when you ask someone if some people are
better than others i'm not making a
judgment on
a person's value i'm i'm i'm analyzing a
very simple statement about whether some
people are better than others
but that doesn't make sense because if
you're better than me at something and
i'm better than you at something then
we're both better than each other it
cancels
it does people are better than you so
you couldn't say that i'm better than
you you couldn't say that you're better
than me because the answer would be no
but you can't equate like skateboarding
with shooting guns or different things
so that's some people are better at
certain this is exactly the point
you're over analyzing the question no
i'm analyzing the question no you're
over analyzing i'm not here i'm not i'm
simply giving you a factual analysis i
think the question
i think you don't understand michael
malus's question this question is too
simplistic
on purpose yeah the point is the right
will simply say yes and the left will
give you an explanation
and that's exactly right whereas we view
it very simply you are going into great
detail about what quantifies
certain things and that's new right
versus new left that's exactly his point
okay i don't think i'm on the left
personally but up to michael malus's
question you would be
okay and that and thanks mike well i
guess it would be
probably better for michael to to more
accurately define
you know how that works but i i
understand
you know it's when i ask this of like
general lefties they'll start saying
like well what do you mean by
better and like well not everybody and
it's like okay there you go like you say
no more that's the point
you know different different world views
and different like
i guess as uh who who made this uh point
who's on the show matt brainard
inductive reasoning versus deductive
reasoning
is like you know your emotions versus
logic etc and things like that
but how about we we derail entirely back
to the discussion about
uh should we talk about the riots in
holland and the civil war coming to the
netherlands yeah
and tie it in with guns because alex is
here and i want to know about
well they don't have guns in guns they
don't no but they could they sure could
they could this is well i don't i don't
know if that would be a good thing or
not
i mean perhaps uh it's a good thing for
individuals to to
have the ability to defend themselves i
think in the context that i'm trying to
say is when people are out in the
streets
fighting and you know fighting you know
there's fear of a civil war maybe we
don't want people escalating the point
the problem is
one side already has guns and they're
using them so
i'm not saying they're using live rounds
in the people in the netherlands but
here's the story
the daily mail says lockdown fury sparks
a third night of violence in holland
with hundreds of protesters looting
shops torching cars and battling police
the netherlands hit by a third night of
riding on monday with clashes in
rotterdam
amsterdam in the hog police and said
police said 184 people had been arrested
by tuesday morning
and promised more arrests would be made
hundreds of riders had looted shops
set fires and clashed with police who
responded with water cannons
he comes into the netherlands introduced
a coronavirus curfew
from 9 00 p.m until 4 30 a.m to bring
cases down
now i believe it was uh the mayor of
eindover who said
that we are on the verge of civil war
and i think it's actually
is it up here i don't know they they
change their articles so much here we go
rioters first struck on sunday night in
amsterdam eindhoven what did i call it
andover
eindhoven and multiple other towns
seeming to catch authorities off guard
and prompting warnings from some
politicians
of civil war john joritsma mayor of
eindhoven
warned bluntly that we are on our way to
civil war
they say despite the unrest many
countries in europe are considering
tightening their lockdowns
this is a this is a uh impossible
conversation an impossible discussion to
be completely honest
people often ask like where's the line
in government intrusion until you say
enough
and then demand a regis of grievances to
the point where there's clashes right
because i tell you in china they're
shoving swabs of people's butts
at a certain point the line has been
breached right
but for now it is a fact that in this
country the line can never be crossed
there's no line there's no point
there's like you could have a bunch of
people who have no plan thinking they're
going to occupy a building
and that's the revolution it's not but
there's there's there's
i think we're at a point where there is
a global security infrastructure that's
not going to allow for that to happen
so it could all break down at some point
when people just lose it i guess
yeah well in the netherlands this is the
third night
of widespread rioting and violence that
even some local politicians are saying
will continue for days
or weeks they burned down many
testing facilities they're they're
fighting police officers in the street
and
this is predominantly over the lockdown
restrictions and specifically this
curfew because a lot of people are
saying
what does the coronavirus not infect you
under a certain time does the
coronavirus have a bedtime
and there have even been studies showing
that curfews are absolutely pointless
and they
do nothing except hinder daily life and
allow the police to have an excuse to
take away your liberties or your money
away from you alex you had something to
say
no it's it's complicated yeah because
we can go deep in like the philosophical
discussion on when
you lose like your national sovereignty
and you start having those civil
the the civil war sort of clashes and
unarmed resistance
and uh you know what happens when one
side of that
when the side of that argument where
where you know the the people who don't
think that their government
has the authority to to sort of rule
over them anymore
um you know what happens when that group
isn't doesn't have any quality of arms
with their their right
for lack of a better term their masters
so
i mean there's there's a real like
philosophical argument to get into
and you see a lot of it in like you in
through portland through the the
the antifa riots um you know a little
bit
a bit of it popped up um in in dc and
i don't know it's it's it's you know you
know you know i think
the the armament of the people changes
the threshold for when those people will
react violently
and so you look at somewhere like china
and the state is a massive security
state with censorship
control of all weapons there's the
likelihood of an uprising is slim to
none
because the odds are so much against the
people
there there's concentration camps in
china right now in the us
it's a bit more precarious because you
have to think about
the amount of pressure on an individual
to make them act and the capability they
have to actually accomplish something
in a place like china or in europe the
ability to accomplish something when you
have an armed state versus an unpopulous
is slim unless you have critical mass
so the line at which it becomes a civil
war like this this you know
dutch mayor is saying is further away
than is in the united states
in the united states you can get one
crazy guy with powerful weapons
who feels he can actually do something
that's scary to me it is
because we want stability we don't want
instability we're not we're not
currently dealing with people getting
anal anally swabbed but we do
have the curtailing of our freedoms i i
think the question is for the u.s even
with the curtailing of our freedoms
we're still pretty much living in in
luxury relative to other places
yeah but also uh against that kind of uh
you know sentiment that you said in
europe all you need is a truck
and and there have been incidences where
there have been
deadly events that have been far more
impactful than shootings in the united
states because of some crazy person
saying i'm just going to run a whole
bunch of people over
with a truck so you know that's another
sentiment here that we need to
understand but what i mean is
if you like if in the us they started
doing mandatory anal swabbing
i imagine things would break down really
fast a lot of social justice warriors
would probably
like that it was probably okay yeah and
so maybe sure if you want to make the
argument then maybe in cities things
would just go along like we've seen
what's going on with new york they just
go for it but think about that the
cities are unarmed
for the most part people in the cities
are not are completely unarmed
and would just go with whatever they're
told then you you i mean just look at
the the militias in this country
and the groups that are armed they tend
not to be living in cities
so either they're moving out for more
freedom or they're more self-reliant and
more
you know don't tread on me you look at
places like the netherlands
the point i'm trying to make is you
require very few people
and much less rage and oppression among
for an armed population to rise up and
say enough
whereas in the netherlands you're going
to have people who are like what am i
going to do about it i can't do anything
i'm on my own
but eventually when you get thousands of
people in the street that's when things
when
that line is crossed so you need more
people and more
oppression for an unarmed population to
finally snap and revolt
which i think is a very simple equation
and explains why governments don't want
people to have guns
especially democrats don't want people
after to have guns which is why i think
you know what you're you know doing uh
uh alex is
is it it's gonna be interesting i guess
the way people say it is the cat's out
of the bag gun control is over yeah
can't can't do sorry i hit the table
can't do much about it it's it's you
know people and
the the the kicker is people have been
making guns in their homes for
the last hundred years before the advent
of 3d printing
now what's the laws with that because i
know some people have you know
don't really know how clear it is what
they can do what can't they do illegally
right so
on the federal level it is entirely
legal if you are able to
federal if you are federally able to
possess a gun so you're not a felon
you're not a domestic abuser
um there are a couple other criteria in
there that i'm not
on the top of the top of the mind you
can't be a drunkard
uh no you can't be i don't know when you
buy a gun it asks you are you a drunkard
and if you put yes they say guy you
can't have a gun no for real yeah yeah
a reform that you have yeah aggressive
or public intoxication
no it just says are you a drunkard or
habitual drinker
that must be an old law yeah and and i
think there's also something oh are you
addicted to alcohol or any other
substance
right yeah yeah and i think there's also
another section about psychological
issues right
or you can't beat your wife yeah or your
husband
right so there are a couple of criteria
that will
uh will disbar you from from owning a
firearm
but if you're able to own it then you
should be able to make it
um you know without any real
hang-ups um mail order parts and
straight to your door
what can't you manufacture locally what
parts
um there aren't any at the moment
you can make a full auto you can you can
you can legally make your own
oh okay no i see sorry i understand you
cannot legally make a
make a machine gun because you cannot
legally possess a machine gun right yeah
all right the law actually stops the
manufacturing machine guns that's it
right you can old
grandfather in machine guns right right
so there was a machine gun registry
before they were forbidden um and you
can
own those they're very expensive
somewhere in the realm of like twenty
thousand dollars for one
what if you had like a gun with 30
barrels that filed
fired 30 rounds the exact same time
that's volley fire which is legal under
the law
really yeah oh i didn't know that see
it's not just thing as a dumb question
yeah there there was a revolver that
came out recently that has two barrels
you fire two i think two 38 specials out
of it i
i could be wrong or two 222's um
but with a with one pull of the trigger
you get two bullets out of two barrels
so only if you want to transfer a
firearm do you have to contact the atf
and get a serial number
for that firearm is that correct uh the
jury is out on that one
okay because the atf usually changes its
mind
right uh more than politicians flip-flop
right and
they're all over the place with their
definitions which are
very confusing they're they're kind of
understandings and their their legal
arguments are
kind of all over the place right so so
to get into the nuts a little
bit it's manufacturing exclusively for
personal use not for sale or
distribution
so if you make it with the intent to
give it away you've committed a felony
if you make it with the intent to sell
it you've committed a felony if you make
it with the intent to use it solely for
yourself for whatever you
are using it for then you're fine wow so
i pulled it up uh i just googled it and
we have
it's it's t-rexsmallarms.com arsenal
firearms af
2011 double barrel pistol in 38 super
yup so it is a handgun with two barrels
it's four thousand dollars five inch
slide
double barrel semi-automatic 38 super
caliber fires both
barrels with one pull of the trigger now
why would you want that
because it looks cool i mean i'm not
saying you shouldn't have it
you can flex on your friends with the
same gun but only one barrel
i'm cooler than you well no but look but
i think about the question the left
often asks is like why would anyone need
this
is there is there first i understand the
immediate response is
it doesn't matter i don't need a reason
i have a second amendment right to own
arms that i get
but is there like a real functional or
tactical reason to having volley fire or
double barrel
you know one trigger pull two bullets
well i mean it it
you're putting twice the amount of of
projectile into whatever you're shooting
at
so if you're you know if you're shoot if
you're hunting bear with an ar-15
you're gonna want more than one round
but you probably shouldn't be hunting
bear with an arrow 15.
so we talked about this though we talked
about um full auto is actually bad
tactically you know tactically generally
speaking it it just wastes a lot of ammo
in in most like a military type
engagement you're going to be shooting
at an individual target
um there is an argument for it where
you're talking about suppressing fire
coming from machine guns um but when you
when you start getting into like fully
auto out of a 30 round magazine it's
kind of
not great like it's it's useful for the
military there's a reason that they have
it if you you know you're in a pinch and
you just
click the button over you know don't
they call it spray and pray
yeah yeah yeah um i just wanted to do a
clarification also when nancy pelosi
lately had said that she wanted crew man
machine guns on these things it's
they're actually called crew served
weapons my friend that was in the army
was like please
tell everyone well we just we just read
what ken cuccinelli said
you know and he said crew men to machine
guns oh he yeah he's part of the
patriarchy
patriarchy so uh crews served well you
can't make full auto
right but that's not that's full auto's
not even a good thing anyway
so it seems kind of redundant yeah i
mean again there's there's an argument
for it
you know if you can control it then you
can be accurate with it and that's the
training thing which you need exposure
to train with it
um so there are arguments for and
against um
are there guns that will automatically
fire when they target
the person uh you're talking like an
automated
turret yeah like if you turn it and it
sees the the
person or the target or the deer or
whatever that then it will fire when it
sees it
yeah kind of there was a company called
tracking point they made a really fun
optic
um and they i i think a later iteration
they built it into a full
rifle platform where you're hunting and
you see the deer and you want to you
want to hit it
at a specific point to get uh you have
to clean kill on it
um and so it would wait until you would
pull the trigger
and then you would like adjust your your
position so you would line up properly
and once it lined up properly it would
fire
um it's been it's been years since i've
seen this
yeah and i i don't know if i'm
remembering it exactly
so don't quote me well you want to make
sure you don't wound a deer because
they're going to run away and they're
going to be injured and they're going to
be suffering there's a specific place on
the deer
i think in the in the lung heart area
correct me if i'm wrong that you have to
if you shoot once it's it's a it's a
pretty good sign that you're it's going
to be a
short a clean kill and and the animal's
not going to suffer right
you know you know i was i was wondering
um i've read a lot about how certain
places have like really high crime like
i hear west virginia has a lot of high
crime and like these a lot of these
places
outside of cities have high crime they
say new york has low crime and i'm like
why is it then that people in west
virginia
there's like not many police around and
then why like you know and people just
get along just fine or get by just fine
then why is it in new york there's like
we're hearing these massive spike in
murders and things like this
wasn't some guy just beaten and stripped
naked in the street in new york yeah i
remember
probably yeah there's a video of it yeah
yeah
yeah i mean i've seen stuff like that in
real life in new york city
growing up i've seen crazy things that
would spark people's ptsd if i described
what i saw
growing up this is uh this is from uh
six to six i'm sorry
i want to pull this up six hours ago man
seen stripped and
beaten in new york city attack was known
gang member with lengthy criminal
history
victim is expected to survive so the 26
year old victim
was in the area of canal and allen
around 11 30 a.m on friday when the
group of about a dozen men and women
jumped him and took a cell phone pants
undergarments and shoes
they then used a sharp object to slice
him in the head hands and torso
the victim was taken to a local hospital
where he's expected to survive on monday
the police commissioner dermot shay
released a 50-second video
of what he called a brazen broad
daylight attack the footage shows the
man running away from the group
as they catch up and begin beating him
police sources told the new york post
the victim lives in brooklyn and had
just returned from atlanta
the violent crew had reportedly been
staking out the nearby bus stop for the
man's arrival
police said they fled in several
vehicles after the attack a law
enforcement source confirmed to fox news
the victim had been linked
to the violent mack baller brims gang
if the shoe was on the other foot he'd
be part of that gang the sword set
source said so is it it's just gang
violence i guess yeah
this is an interesting thing like
chicago is an interesting gun
conversation
chicago's got a bunch of people with
illegal guns and they go around shooting
each other all the time
and i think that's what the left uses an
argument for gun control
criminals who take the guns and then are
causing
problems and murdering people over the
place i guess for me i've always kind of
wondered
if the guns are already illegal and
they're committing murders with them why
would passing a law stop them from
committing a murder which is already
illegal i mean like that's the worst
crime yeah well we're killing somebody
we see a lot of deliberations one of the
worst
we see a lot of liberals talk about gun
homicides and they keep forgetting that
most of them are from
illegal guns and jurisdictions that
already banned them
other uh gun deaths are because of
suicide and then i think
the third uh highest level of guns death
rates are from police officers shooting
people
so so if you're for you know gun control
you're not
really for gun control you're for having
individuals with guns take away other
people's guns at the threat of using
guns that's essentially what you're for
and you should just be honest about it
that you want people
robbed of their ability to defend
themselves while of course the
politicians
want literal machine guns protecting
them all the time
i like the the idea of having an armed
society is kind of cool because
if if some group does rise up to
overthrow the government with guns which
lake and holland are probably afraid of
you have the rest of the population also
armed to protect the country
from the overthrow civil war well
ideally
i mean that's possible that did happen
in the 1800s but ideally
it would it would be a swift justice
they always say that with one
man i mean we've got 75 million trump
voters 80 million biden voters but it's
better than i think a totalitarian
dictatorship the threat of civil war is
better than a totalitarian dictatorship
the threat of civil war it's better to
know that there's a possib like
the idea that a civil war could happen
means that the dictatorship is less
likely to happen
you always want to reduce harm and and
what usually reduces harm
as individuals being able to defend
themselves because people
then don't take uh offensive aggressive
actions against them
they say an armed society is a polite
society and i think we're seeing that in
places like florida in places like texas
where
people have the ability to protect
themselves unlike other jurisdictions
like chicago
new york city uh and and a lot of the
other big cities where you can't and
gang violence and uh has been
skyrocketing because all the gang
members know people
are defenseless people can't defend
themselves if they do have a firearm but
now in many places
i think in chicago you can have a gun
but i i think it's really difficult
for i grew up there in the longest time
like all weapons were just outright
banned i think the only legal weapon
you're allowed to have is
a rubber switch you know you know what
that is it's like a long piece of rubber
with a little ball at the end and you
whack people with it
what about a knife no knives that's
illegal yeah
in times square the biggest arrests that
were made were individuals
that came in from out of new york who
had pocket knives the biggest arrests
that happened
i i forgot the exact statistic here but
but i i
heard a very wild one that the the
majority of arrests in new york happened
because of tourists having
guns on their you know oh right yeah i
imagine it's like a knife of a certain
length
yeah it's like longer than three and a
half inches or something so that's like
a pocket knife you get a certain pocket
knife
or maybe you've got like a utility knife
or something you carry around for
nail clippers yeah yeah and they're like
well that's a crime
can't have that um alex do you know how
many
3d printed guns are in existence is that
even measurable um
not really i mean i i broke 25 000
across socials so i
imagine there's at least 25 000. um
i i would severe i would surely hope
that there are many many many times that
number
and i i believe that there are but i i
would have
no one there's no way to count because
most people are making them in the
privacy of their own home
and if they're doing it right they're
not telling anybody so we we were
talking about this
uh like last week i think about ghost
guns and some people were saying they
were illegal and then a bunch were like
no no they're totally legal
so ghost guns are legal is that correct
yeah so if you a minute ago we're
talking about
like how you can manufacture any gun you
manufacture at home
for your own personal use is what
politicians are calling a ghost gun
like they're they're they're one the
same so it's not just 3d printed stuff
it's not just like the
the 80 kits that you buy it's it's
anything that you're making at home
so what's how does the 80 kit work so uh
basically a co a a company when it said
uh
went to the atf and said hey is this
uh so okay i need to back up the atf
regulates
once one specific part of a firearm that
is the f
as a firearm it's the serialized part
it's the one part that you actually have
to go to an ffl a gun store to buy
and what part is that it varies based on
the firearm on a glock it's the polymer
frame
uh on an ar-15 it's the lower receiver
where the trigger
and the magazine go into um so that's
the serialized part
now what these 80 companies did is they
went to the etf and they had
a partially finished one they sent them
the the lawyer and said hey is this a
firearm yet
the atf said no so the the industry
called it an 80
complete firearm so it's not quite a
firearm
and you can you can buy it it ships
straight to your door and you finish it
on
basic tools uh there's a couple of kits
out there one you do with like a
a dewalt router or something some kind
of
common hardware tool or you can do it
with a drill press but then you still
need to buy that last piece
right wasn't there something going on
with people saying the atf was rating
people for having these kits
yeah so there was one specific kit done
by polymer 80 called the buy build shoot
kit
and they market it as everything you
need in a box to build a gun
in a couple hours and you would click it
once and you add to the cart and they
would ship it to your door and then
you'd spend an hour putting it together
and the atf said that this box of parts
that weren't fought that wasn't a
firearm
was close enough to the definition of a
firearm
and marketed in such a way that it could
be construed as a firearm that it was
actually a firearm
which doesn't make any sense right from
the legal perspective but this is the
etf we're talking about
they you know fairy dust and magic so in
terms of 3d printed guns you're printing
what like the frame the grip
the stock or what yeah basically any
external part
that has complex geometry so some things
that are going to be difficult to make
by hand
and then looking specifically at like
the fgc 9
the barrel and the bolt are made at home
out of common and common material
and again the barrel where we're
finishing it
with basically 3d printable inserts and
we're using electrochemical
machining to get the internal dimensions
of the barrel to the right size
and rifle it and cut the chamber and it
sounds really complicated it does i was
like what
yeah i know that shot really high for a
lot of people
but uh there's a good write up on on
whoa it was auto playing a video from
about the ftc nine
continue continue anyway a lot of that
went over a lot of people's heads
there's a really good write-up
it's it sounds really complicated it's
not you're
you've it's salt water and an aquarium
pump and a five gallon bucket in your
garage so
in total how much do you have to spend
on supplies materials
and everything you need to to make a
fgc9
okay so the the hardware to get started
the printer itself
200 bucks yeah filament 40 bucks
the parts to build the actual gun your
internals about another 200 bucks
and then your your um your bench top
power supply
and your aquarium pump to do the
electrochemical machining
is like another 100 on top of that so
when you say electrochemical machining
right you have salt water in a tank how
does that work exactly so
you you're pumping water out of a bucket
salt water out of a bucket
through the inside of the barrel and
you've got a
an electrode in the barrel that
stripping
material at the atomic level awesome off
of the inside of the barrel
to bore it to the right size for your
bullet and then cut rifling and then cut
in your chamber
wow that sounds really hard to do yes
it's not awesome
it's not hard because someone gave us a
super chat a couple days ago they're
like no it's so easy you could just
print on
an fgc9 and i looked in i was like this
looks hard yeah
this looks really hard look it looks
hard it's super easy
um what caliber is fgc9 it's a
nine-millimeter nine
is that where the nine comes from yeah
um yeah yeah and then the fcg
uh fgc means something else yeah f
gun control are there other printers
than the ender like uh next level
above the under five um there are uh you
start to lose the value
per dollar that you're spending so you
can get into like a three or four
thousand dollar printer pretty quickly
what would be the value of that
uh i mean you're doing the same thing
you're doing on the under under five
does it print
about the same quality you might get an
upgraded materials you might be able to
print with some fancy nylons and stuff
like that
some higher temperature stuff but i mean
for the price difference what about
metal do you print metal no
so metal is a whole another uh um
manufacturing process and it's a lot
more to get into
so um there there's a couple different
methods of doing the most popular
the cheapest one and i'll start at this
is fifty thousand dollars
that you're spending to get in here wow
it's a laser
that melts a layer of powder and then uh
the printer scoops another layer on top
of it and
does another layer of melting those are
really fast though right no it goes
really slow
yeah it's pretty slow wow um and then
once all that's done you have to take
that part you have to send it to another
company to do the final like
actually make it a solid part because
it's a bunch of particles that are stuck
together
it's gotta go like a kiln or something
right like where it heats and solidifies
or something like that yeah
and then you have to add material
physically add additional materials to
it
so it becomes a lot more expensive a lot
more costly there's applications for it
but not for like the home gunsmith
i'm gonna do this in my garage for the
cheap um
like there are there are filaments that
have metal embedded in them but they
have the same problem
where it's just a bunch of medical metal
particles that are just
stuck together and then you have to send
it to another company to finish it
i got to be honest man you say it sounds
easy but i'm like looking at these
websites and it's just
there's hurdles to you know the average
person can't just do this yeah no
everything is a learning curve but uh
we've tried to make it really really
simple so
in order to get started i'm going to
plug my site go go to
theguide.controlpew.com
uh that'll get you your first 10 steps
into 3d printing
you're not 3d printing guns yet you're
just 3d printing you're just learning
how to use the printer
how to use the software how to get it
dialed in so it actually functions and
things fit together properly
and then the next step right find a gun
you want to print
print it and control p is
p c-t-r-l-e-w c-t-r-l-p-e-w that's
theguyan.controlpew.com and just to
clarify
having and making your own fgc 9 is
legal federally
is that correct federally it's legal uh
state laws may vary i know maryland has
some funny business going on i know
california
has funny business going on i know new
york has funny business going on
well california and maryland banned
flamethrowers
they're they're the two states and i
know this because i own a flamethrower
they banned flamethrowers which is just
utterly ridiculous
and so unamerican i'm sorry i thought
this was a miracle
people are getting in trouble with the
the elon musk flamethrowers yeah
because people were buying them and it's
called not a flamethrower by the boring
company
and then people are getting the fed
string up the door being like that's a
flamethrower the funny business is
that's actually a weed burner
it's not a flamethrower it just has a
little bit of flame that sits in the end
it doesn't throw the flame everywhere
and it's really depressing and i'm
really sad about it
now now importantly making your own 3d
printed firearm like the fgc9
is there any legislation against doing
this
locally statewide is there anything
against 3d printing on the books now
because i've seen
individuals like chuck schumer who
literally
explain explain the black what was it
the silk road
in in such a way where it promoted it on
national television a few years ago now
talking about
the ease of 3d printing firearms there's
a lot of misunderstanding but but is
there any legislation proposed or or
on the books now against 3d printing
federally state or local
not at the federal level at the state
level like i said california maryland
new york i think there is some
legislation that exists
although how far you get with that i
don't know there's a couple people
um reno is a guy from a youtuber from
california
he's working on a 3d printed california
compliant
glock and ar15 so
there are some specifics to work within
those sets of laws
but i i'm not as well read on the
individual states to be able to answer
that with any level of competence well
you know even traveling with firearms
you
you learn about so many of the
jurisdictions reciprocities and
you literally need to hire a lawyer to
explain it to you because of the
different
made-up laws that each politician
interprets in their own
unique ways which is uh again not
universal and very confusing
and it leads a lot of people in trouble
yeah i'm so
i'm so disappointed because i tried for
like i sat for like three four hours i
dug through the law to come out here
with my trunk of fun
yeah and just show you guys what we're
working with and i couldn't do it
because i just couldn't figure out how
to navigate
the whole thing properly and i was like
okay i can't yeah i can't even
begin have you in your time 3d printing
and experimenting have you ever
figured out new shapes to build weapons
or guns with that make them more
effective
um i mean a little bit so we we've done
a lot of modifications on like the ar-15
to make it a lot more robust
there's a version now that has an
additional like
bracket on the on the side of it to hold
the buffer tower
to add some extra support to the buffer
tower so that it doesn't break off when
you're shooting
which was a problem that we had with
like the early 2015-2016 versions of the
air 15 lower
so i mean we we've we've come along
we've evolved in a lot of different
uh different firearms so like when
you're talking about specific shapes
not really but it it all varies based on
the forces applied to each firearm
because they all they all act a little
bit differently
yeah i'm thinking like to print like
little hooks on the side where you could
stick extra cartridges
and then to hold okay yeah no that stuff
there's a lot of that actually um
thingiverse doesn't allow you to do gun
stuff but there's a lot of gun stuff on
thingiverse it's fantastic
so yeah your stuff on thingiverse too
well there is that
a lot of weird stuff is everything yeah
they got weird stuff on thingiverse oh
that's awesome the future is is now it's
unstoppable wonderful they're going to
make 3d printers that can print 3d
printers
just around the corner so funny story
2012 the reprap
project which started the whole 3d
printer business and like the commercial
you know home use um they were designed
to be
have a bunch of 3d printed parts and
then have a bunch of comment off the
shelf parts
or you just printed the stuff you need
or you had someone else print it for you
and then you assembled your printer and
you could print another set and give
them to someone else
and they could build their printer so
cool so that was the origin of this
whole thing
which is another reason why the whole
three 3d printing thing itself can never
really be stopped because the origin of
everything is open source
it's all out there it's all public
domain they could put some kind of tax
on 3d printers where you have to get a
stamp and then
only one office in the country issues
the stamps and they're swamped and
people can only get one like every six
months
like they do with many things to get
around the law you know what i mean
right but
prove that i bought the printer to you
know
you know what i mean well i mean like
you know what we've seen you gotta catch
them first
what we've seen with a lot of uh
regulations the government does when
they can't ban something is they put
regulatory hurdles in front of it
that are so severe people eventually
just stop doing it i have a feeling that
in the future they'll be trying to ban
the
information like the actual cad files
so when electricity becomes free like
once we once we tap fusion and we're in
ignition
um it's going to be the information
that's the currency of the world
it's funny i was watching star trek
earlier and i'm just thinking about this
now like
what if like could you imagine someone
walking up to a replicator and being
like computer
glock nine millimeter glock 17 it's not
loaded give me a
50 rounds just appears and people have
guns right wouldn't that be great
isn't the data market more valuable than
the oil market in the world already that
wouldn't surprise you so
i mean when we're looking at the
advancements of technology it goes both
ways it provides people a lot of
opportunity but it also
has an opportunity to take away a lot of
the freedoms and liberties that we take
advantage of so it's going to be
interesting because when you look at 3d
printers and trying to ban them i mean
essentially
when you boil it down it's somewhat of a
simple technology of of just
making plastic hot and then moving
around a machine so
it uses that heat and that you know
melted plastic to to shape something in
a different form
so i mean it's going to be very hard to
ban 3d printers but
it's something that as you said could
happen and could be regulated in a way
where it's impossible to
for the for the fgc 9 could you just buy
like standard parts for other guns is
that legal
like if you bought a barrel or certain
parts that you needed yeah
so there are a couple mods that exist
already one to make it take glock barrel
or glock
glock barrels uh another one to
oh it's uh by by default it takes an
ar-15 fire control group
funny story that air 15 fire control
group is also like
a one-to-one copy of one that you can
get out of an airsoft gun
on aliexpress yeah oh wow yeah but so so
that becomes extremely easy then yeah
like what what's what's the regulatory
issue then do you still have to get
serialized you have to get it registered
or anything like that no so if you're if
you're building it for personal use
there's no serial number no registration
nothing it just exists and it's yours
and now you have gun
so you can buy the the metal parts you
need
and then 3d print the rest put together
and you're good to go yep that's crazy
do you ever use
resin printing i've started messing with
some of it uh the biggest problem with
resin printing is it's
structurally weaker than fdm printing or
the plastic printing
so the part you get isn't as strong so
it breaks
sooner um so i've seen a couple people
try and do like glock frames in their
resin printers
and they don't end well um they no
injury to the user
but there's break they just break how
long is this like so we were talking
about how the liberator
i i remember when it you know was first
being developed it would get off like
one or two a few rounds and then just
break itself but that was no metal parts
right right well
it would it's over the firing pin common
nail yeah a common nail yeah
and how would that would just be one a
one-off or what uh well okay
so you can get more than one round out
of a liberator
the the video that's been that's
commonly cited is one from like the
queensland police who printed a really
crappy version of it
it was they didn't follow the
instructions and this is critical
follow the readme there's a readme in
every package everything gives out it's
got
the instructions follow them
but uh they didn't follow the readme uh
so their print was junk and it blew up
because but did it actually fire though
like one it did fire the one round
it also blew up uh they get hurt no they
had it on a stand
but i know cody in his 2013 video fired
three or four
rounds through his on video on camera
in succession so i mean
you just put a nail in it yeah that's
amazing
what do you think about the new biden
kind of proposals for gun control have
you looked into them
at all i mean i've tried but they are
not very coherent and don't really apply
to a lot
it sounds like a universal ban on all
things
pew pew yeah and
okay enforce it yeah exactly i mean i
think they will no
law-abiding citizens obey the law can't
enforce that's the problem
with the with the amount of guns that
are being printed there's just that
that's that's
look looking at this last year alone
just with like the
the reported background checks there's
something like three
we're like 10 million new shooters i
feel like we're butting up against four
million background checks
yeah now a lot of those background
checks have more than one gun and not
all of those background checks
actually complete or end in a sale but
four million is i think it's way more
than that actually yeah i i feel like it
would be too and i'm i'm ballparking
numbers so again
so the i think the guy from federal ammo
put out a video about the ammo shortage
and said that we're looking at seven
million new shooters oh geez so that
means
background checks has to has to be over
seven million yeah because some people
buy more than one gun yeah
so a lot of yeah well actually no that's
not fair because some people are buying
some people are already going owners
under buying guns so maybe you're right
maybe it is four million
so the the data that comes up when i
just oh no i'm sorry it would have to be
more than seven yeah regardless of your
first time shooter or not yeah the data
that comes up
that when i just searched for this is
that nearly 5
million new gun owners have joined the
100
million plus gun owners already in the
united states in 2020 according to
recent estimates for the
from the national shooting sports
foundation so uh
some of the data also shows that 40 of
all firearms sales are going through
first-time buyers
so of course there's a lot of people i
mean i've saw this i started doing
uh you know trainings with my special
forces green beret friends in new
hampshire teaching people who are
first-time
gun owners how to properly use how to
properly clean
use their firearms this summer because
there was a demand for it and there was
a shortage of professionals willing to
train people
how to even safely use and operate a
firearm let's let's segue into this next
this next story
from newsweek fact check did missouri
shop say no
guns and ammo for biden supporters guess
what
fact check true it actually happened
they say
president joe biden preached that the
country requires unity to overcome its
challenges in
his inaugural address last week as it
remains divided with the capital riots
earlier this month blah blah blah
in missouri depending on the
presidential candidate you one voted for
some local residents might not be able
to obtain guns or ammunition at one
store
austin peterson tweeted my local gun
shop announced last night
they do not have any guns or ammunition
available for biden supporters
the comment section of howling leftists
is delicious like hot apple pie with ice
cream
let's keep it going is it the claim the
tweet from him is the claim
a user from the social media forum gab
posted a screenshot of an article
from the gateway pundit an online
political news blog that says we report
the truth and leave the russia collusion
fairy tale to the conspiracy media
with the headline missouri gun shop
announces they don't have guns or ammos
for biden supporters
they have the actual post from facebook
here it's true trigger firearms and
reloading llc
based in jefferson city missouri
recently posted to its facebook business
page
we don't have guns or ammo for biden
supporters sorry for the inconvenience
the company that lists itself as a gun
store on the platform has received more
than 3 000 interactions
and more than 1 000 shares on the post
with mixed reactions from users in the
comment thread
reached by phone trigger firearms and
reloading llc hung up on newsweek's
request for comment about the facebook
post
declining to respond gee you think
facebook user terry plotner wrote
private company so they can do what they
want
but in a comment responding to the gun
shops post an apparent support the
ruling true
they did say this they will not sell
guns or ammo so what does that mean like
you walk in and they're like who'd you
vote for
and you're like i voted for joe biden
get out yeah who's gonna admit that
a gun shop i don't think they're going
to admit it i don't think they're going
to be asking but this is great pr to
bring attention to their gun store
i know a gun store in new hampshire that
literally had joe biden as the salesman
of the month
a few weeks ago and that brought in a
whole bunch of attention and a lot of
people angry and a lot of people pissed
off and he's like i love it give me all
the attention
uh the guy was also a fan of we are
change which is awkward walking in there
and it's like oh of course yeah it's
amazing
where's where where are the people going
to banks asking for
multi-million dollar investment to start
primer companies or powder companies
because the shortage of all this ammo
yeah like now is the opportunity to get
on the ground floor
in fact can you 3d print ammo oh we're
getting there
so we've got a couple people working on
it um
developments are coming we've got we've
got projectiles we've got casings
we're working on we've got half the
chemistry we're working 3d printed
projectile
not no so we're 3d printing molds that
will let you cast projectiles in any
caliber and diameter you want because in
many places in the world you can't buy
the molds
but it's incredible let me let me ask
you would you provide
all of your schematics to biden's voters
sure yeah i don't care
yeah they're they're going on the
internet for free
yeah anyone can download them yep go
nuts everyone will have them if they
want them
i guess that's the point you know if
it's it's freedom it's
you as an individual have the ability of
the technology you can do it
you know i was thinking about what like
you know why these liberals like these
binding supporters are so concerned and
will well first of all let me say
they're willing to support
they're willing to support a man who
says he's going to outright ban all gun
sales and accessory sales online
do you want to ban ammo too online sales
of ammo yeah i do recall
yeah he wrote a lot of vague generalized
language about not allowing people to
buy a firearm uh within a certain amount
of period
close to another purchase of a firearm
he talked about banning online sales i
don't have anything gun related
how could you vote for him and then
actually go and expect to buy a gun yeah
and that's a weird question out right
like is how many people are actually
going to this gun shop and saying
they're biden supporters who want to buy
guns
i guess they exist but it's like all
right i'll tell you what you give
no you have to give it to me like it's
being confiscated you don't you don't
and it's interesting that this is
oh you got a stink bug in there yeah
it's interesting that this is happening
in missouri because in missouri this is
also where the mccloskey case happened
i'm still trying to look up the latest
information about what's happening with
them but there are the couple that
walked out with firearms with
very poor trigger discipline and very
point very poor
aim discipline uh when a blm uh you know
pretty much protest broke down the fence
of their door and uh
you know they say threatened them so i'm
still trying to find out exactly what's
going on what should they have
done like had their guns pointed down at
the ground well when you see
i think it was patricia mccloskey she
literally had
her finger on the trigger and she was
moving the gun around
in a place where it was rightly behind
her husband's head
you're not supposed to do that that's
not smart that's not smart
i feel like everything else was
appropriate given the information that i
have like it was it was a violent crowd
and you're
you're they're they're confronting you
on your property so
i feel like that's okay to point a gun
at them with your finger on the trigger
and be like i'm actually going to shoot
you if you keep coming out they were on
this property in a castle doctrine state
right
so it's like in in some states you can
shoot some before before they even get
on your property
if in order to prevent someone entering
your property some states allow you to
shoot someone's hardcore
yeah and so there's like uh i don't know
the full details but some states like
new jersey i think new jersey is duty to
retreat meaning
you're in your home in the middle of the
night and you're allowed to own a gun
and then someone breaks in if you can
flee your home you must
but it's really funny because i was
talking to even a cop about this and he
laughed and he was like where are you
gonna go it's your house
where do you go it makes no sense and i
was like yeah and then in other states
they have
castle doctrine with no dude no duty to
retreat but
a duty to enter your home so like let's
say you live in you know maryland
and you're on your front lawn or
something and you see someone coming
towards you
you have to go into your house first
then if they try breaking in
you can defend your home in places i
think like west virginia i'm pretty sure
west virginia's like you seem on your
property you can shoot them yeah
in new york city you defend yourself you
hurt the perp
you go to jail for the crime of hurting
the perp so i know many instances in
cases where people
had violence brought upon them they
defended themselves and because they
left a mark
on the the attacker the aggressor they
went to jail really yeah what you're
supposed to do no
there's even individuals there's even
stories in the united states where
people were violently attacked
fought back and uh you know
with with extreme cases of even you know
people trying to kill another person
that person defended themselves and they
went to jail so
there's a number of cases it all depends
on the jurisdictions and it all depends
on who the attorney general is
and this is why we've seen individuals
like george soros literally
bankroll authority attorney generals all
throughout the country that of course
will play favorable into the agenda and
to the narratives that they want to push
the moral of the story is simple don't
live in blue states or blue cities yes
yeah you have to go somewhere where
you're allowed to be reasonable
defenders when you do go
leave all of those policies there yes
that's amazing you see you see this
story earlier about a guy from cal he
from california moved to texas
and then was like really upset and angry
like he called it it was not a
conservative utopia
and it was like mono culture just didn't
like it so he leaves and it's like
you know what man that's a good story
you know why he left
yeah he didn't like it he left it's it's
remarkable because
you know we have so many people now
fleeing these big cities and going to
these these red areas where i can
understand why this store is basically
saying
no biden supporters can buy guns because
you've got democrats from
big cities moving to red areas bringing
those policies with them
and then they want to buy guns and then
get them banned later what's the point
like crate crate grandfathered in guns
that only you can sell like like full
auto
you know what do they cost like 20 grand
for for a
like a belt fed full auto machine gun uh
yeah belt fed you're gonna get way up in
there but
because it's grandfathered in the only
way to own it is if it's an existing
right there's a finite number
a lot of people want them so maybe
that's the plan maybe it's a bunch of
rich people being like if we get guns
banned then only we have the guns it'll
be worth a million bucks
there you go that's a racket yeah the
guy who moved uh
to texas and then back i mean one of the
top reasons he left is because the the
weather was oppressive
that uh that there was no public land
that there was no snowy mountains that
that the people in austin were rude but
uh you know
you went to justin austin's yeah yeah
yeah
they have a liberal mayor there who goes
to uh vacation in the caribbean islands
while telling everyone to stay home and
not travel because of covid
uh just like most democratic politicians
who don't follow the law but
i mean this guy sparked an interesting
discussion but i do believe
media organizations like the daily mail
went too far
they kind of doxed him they released
public information about his house where
he lived
his family photos and i'm like this is
too far this is i mean people are
enjoying
calling him the new karen and duncan on
him but but for me but it was his old
house
yeah he didn't live there anymore well i
i don't know it looks they're showing
how
his house in in los angeles uh sorry san
diego
and his house in uh texas that he had
yeah he doesn't live it
it's still a lot of personal information
that's not really needed there and a lot
and a lot of people were ragging on the
guy and i'm like but he did the right
thing yeah he moved there
hated it and left exactly there you go
if you don't like it and
you you move that's fine and we
shouldn't be criticizing him
he does smart spark an interesting
conversation which i think we all should
have
and uh that should be it you know you
know what i think ultimately the biggest
problem is
it's that conservatives who live in
conservative areas understand what city
life is like to a certain degree
and don't care for what people do in
cities but people live in cities have no
idea what rural life is like and want
everyone to live under the rules of a
city
like so so i talked about it before if
you live in manhattan uh
even even i think luke accidentally came
out in support
of regular gun regulation when i said
what happens if you live in new york
city and you got it you got a 556 and
someone breaks into your cubicle
apartment
and you said maybe maybe don't allow
certain calibers
well maybe some individuals we had this
argument i'm like tim you should get a
shotgun
i don't know my my walls in my rv are
kind of thin there
well so the point is i'll ask you alex
uh in new york for instance
i understand the right to bear arms
especially to defend yourself if you
live in one of these cubicle
loft apartments where you got 30 people
surrounding your your you know 10 by 10
cube that smells like sour milk and
someone breaks into your apartment
a certain uh you know a certain bullet's
going to go through walls and
potentially hit other people and that
could create a huge risk
yeah so all bullets are going to go
through walls like there is no bullet
small enough that it's going to stop in
drywall
even like a with a hollow point 22 yeah
it would go
it would go through but i mean like but
just assume that it's going to because
this is
this is sort of the danger you get into
with gun ownership
of you're responsible for wherever that
bullet goes
period so if it goes through who you
shot into the 12 year old and
two apartments down well that you know
you may have shot the guy yes
but the consequence of that you know was
you've you've created an unacceptable
consequence of that you killed a 12 year
you shot a 12 year old
so i mean this is something that a gun
owner needs to be conscious
of this is something that you get
through exposure to firearms in general
is you develop this knowledge over time
man could you imagine
living in new york city and there being
a gun shop in times square where they're
selling like a 308 and you buy it well
it's also clarify you know i'm not for
the regulation
but but there is there is a particular
gun culture
that that needs to be talked about
because when we went out to the range we
met a lot of random individuals in the
middle of the woods
away from all the roads and they were
all courteous they all looked you in
your eye they all talked to you they all
treated you with respect
there was no attitude there was no you
know crap thrown your way there is a
particular gun culture
that is that takes safety very seriously
that makes sure
that you don't point your muzzle at
people regardless of whether the gun is
loaded or not loaded yes but but luke
it's not about gun culture it's about
regular people yeah like
think about how remember you made that
video about being on the subway with all
those people everywhere
yes so luke made this video a long time
ago about being on the subway with
millions of people just keep going you
got nothing else to lose
and they never talk to each other but
how often like we see videos of attacks
they happen
but how often does the average person
walk through new york walking past all
these people and no one just randomly
starts beating your staff same way with
driving you never really
veer the car over and ram into someone
you know you know when i when i was 16
and like well actually i got my license
i was 18. but when i was like first
starting to learn how to drive
i was shocked when i when i realized the
cars don't frequently bump into each
other
like how's that possible you got to park
cars got to bump into each other it's
like well sometimes when you're parallel
parking you might bump somebody
but for the most part millions upon
millions of cars every day
drive within inches of each other and
never touch and i was like
wow especially taxi drivers they they
they drive like
crazy yeah freaking i don't know think
about that
and then when i when we went to the
range and there were some other dudes
there setting up targets and they had a
bunch of guns too
i have no no fear or no concern about
them shooting me or anybody else because
i don't regularly get attacked by random
people especially when you're at a range
when people are going there for a
purpose well people
people who live in cities are paranoid
and terrified that someone's gonna
you know what you know what it is maybe
maybe because there's too many nasty
people who work in these offices or on
twitter
and they know that they're they're bad
people and they're just worried about
someone coming to their office and you
know
going postal yeah desperation can breed
violence obviously and in cities
sometimes you have poverty and
hunger but trust is like such an
integral part of being human you know we
got to where we are as the socially
constructed
species by trusting each other and also
i think people when they decide to
purchase a firearm they understand that
they're taking a very serious
responsibility that it comes with a lot
of training a lot of educating
and a huge huge uh you know patience
towards trying to understand
the the huge ramifications and i think
majority of people
do that i thought the first thing
everybody did when they bought guns was
to go out in the parking lot like
yosemite sandwich and start firing
wildly into the air
yeah yeah with some revolvers yeah what
kind of gun you think yosemite sand was
using is that like a 45 acp
um 45 long colt i would say it's a
44 magnum
what was i'm thinking about like the
stereotype of the character is what kind
of bullet they used back then
oh okay hold on i don't know somebody
38 38 yeah i don't know i'm sure someone
in super chat will correct me
i'm sorry someone in the chat will
correct me speaking of corrections i do
want to go back
uh we were talking about nick's earlier
nick's background checks so
the 2020 annual total was 21.1
million background check background
checks so
again not all background checks result
in sale and not all background checks
are one-to-one with firearms
right and not all states require
background checks to buy a firearm wait
really
yeah so if you have a permit like right
i have a i have a carry permit in iowa i
don't have to do a background check
right
a concealer a concealed carry or uh
right iowa is just a carry
oh wow i think and then if one person
buys 20 guns they only need to do one
background check
not if you have a permit you just walk
it and you go i'll take that all the
depends on the state
yeah but but it's to clarify the permit
is a background check yes you had to get
one to get the permit right right that
was just one
yeah yeah so it's it's weird that you
know so during during the march for our
lives protest i went down there
in a good faith attempt at talking to
people i can't tell you how many people
were like holding up signs saying
assault ban assault rifles and so i
would talk to them and be like i just
want to ask you about your sign and
they'd be like yeah what about it i'd be
like
well assault rifles are illegal and
they've always been
and i'm wondering if you were aware or
what your goal
is with the sign and they would go oh
and like one lady like folded it up it's
like i didn't know
and i'm like uh-huh what's an assault i
mean it's kind of a vague uh
assault rifle how would you define an
assault rifle
well it's not really defined so assault
rifle
selective fire rifle yes and no because
that's that's
in the legal definition that is a
machine gun
right so the assault rifle is like the
populist term that politicians like to
use
to scare people assault weapon assault
rifle is a is a is a rifle that has
selective fire so you can do
single burst or full auto in the
colloquial that is but
the i think this is a legal term we're
talking about legal terminology this is
the machine gun because they're talking
about legislation and passing laws what
the
what the legislature what the democrats
tend to do and some republicans
is they say assault weapon and they
can't define what an assault weapon is
right so like we were talking about this
i don't know if we're talking about in
the air but like
the m1a is illegal in maryland but the
scar
what does luke have the scar 22 oh i
shouldn't have 20 scar 20 i shouldn't be
talking about that publicly i guess but
anyway oh well too late heads out of the
bag
the the m1a is illegal in in maryland
because it's a weapon of war i guess
but it's like the m1a is is it fair to
say it's like relatively archaic
the m1 garand was what world war ii yes
and so it's
not it's not the same as like a modern
ar-15 that could shoot the same caliber
which is probably more efficient
and easier to use yeah so the the point
is the assault
weapon definition is like nonsensical
almost
and i know gun owners know this and
they've known this longer than i did
because you see the memes where it's
like this is illegal this is legal
they're literally the same gun
you know it's like minor differences
assault rifle means it means selective
fire which does that always mean that it
has a full auto selection
single burst or full auto so okay so
machine gun
talking going back to legal term the
machine gun is any weapon that fires
more than one bullet with a single pole
of the trigger oh so burst fire
so burst fire full auto um anything of
that
that nature um when you talk about
assault weapons assault rifles
these are these are vague and undefined
terms which is why well i sort of
i'm pretty sure assault assault rifle is
defined so
uh it was popularized by hitler the term
assault rifle
and it's a selective fire rifle that
uses an intermediate cartridge and a
detachable magazine
they were first put into mass production
accepted in wide use during world war ii
the first rifles were the german stg44
assault weapon
is the nonsensical term that has no
right like a flamethrower could be an
assault weapon they assaulted
there's some trenches that are assault
weapons i guess what i'm trying to
what i'm trying the language i'm trying
to focus on is like what's in u.s
law because assault weapon and assault
rifle aren't defined anywhere
in us except for by hitler apparently
except by hitler rifle
selective fire burst fire so they think
ars are assault rifles by first
definition and the the reason they think
that is because they look very similar
to the
common combat rifle issued to our
you know oh yes ars don't fire burst but
they don't fire burst they're not
machine guns so they're not assaulted so
they're not
any any what is category so you
mentioned volley fire earlier right
right
let's say you had a gun with like you
say was a 556 with like 15 barrels
what if when you pull the trigger one
time it goes like i run in a circle like
in a sequence is that full auto
or would that be considered volley i
think that's considered volley fire so
it would function effectively i don't
the accuracy would not be the same as
full auto actually it might be better i
mean i mean we're
we're we're we're chasing into the
territory we're like i'm not a legal
expert i don't actually know
um also like i i feel like
it all depends on the mechanism because
if you
pull the trigger once and it's like a
physical well even then
i don't know how you would initiate all
of that
it's we get into a technical argument
and you need to send it to the atf to
be evaluated there's some crazy guns so
i just google searched it there's the
s-333 volley fire
it's a prototype six-barreled pepper box
styled pocket pistol
there's a lot of things like what is
this one is that binary fire
is that what we're talking about no so
binary fire is a whole nother thing
where you
pull the trigger yeah and it fires one
round and then you let go of the trigger
and it fires another round and this
is not a machine gun because the law
specifies a machine gun as a single
operation of the trigger so just pulling
the trigger
is a single operation and letting the
trigger go is another operation
so is that cool yeah except in some
states like iowa iowa you can't have
binary triggers
as far as what if you just had multiple
triggers um
so you could like play the guitar like
and you're going
with your fingers like playing the bass
i mean design it
yeah yeah like there's nothing that says
that you can't make it
and then see what happens oh yeah like
you have a trigger but it's actually
three small slivers of triggers that you
pull all three triggers
and then it fires three rounds no you
need three fingers to pull one two three
and you can go one two three one two
three one two three one three you might
not actually you might you might be able
to just line three triggers up and pull
them
well then they might consider that
single trigger pull well no because you
have three distinct triggers
and three distinct operating mechanisms
within that call a lawyer
right you can have nine triggers
one on each finger it's like it's like
bump fire it effectively allowed people
to fire full auto
and so they're like no that's got to be
illegal and it's interesting because
it does right so what you know it's just
people are going to keep finding
different ways to make different kinds
of guns
eventually there's going to be this
weird shaped you know octagonal box
with like pipes coming out the sides and
you put your hands in it and then it
does full auto
and it's some crazy loophole to the law
that allows it to function
you know when you're you're playing the
accordion and it's like i think i'm
familiar with the bump stock can you
explain the bump how it seems full auto
so
oh no you man okay so when you're
holding the rifle you're push
the stock and the the rifle itself are
not fixed together so they they slide
uh you know forward to back so you're
pulling the rifle the stock against your
shoulder come up on the mic when you're
telling sorry you're pulling you're
pulling the stock against your shoulder
and you're pushing like the front the
barrel the hand guard forward
and then yeah what happens is when
there's there on where your finger goes
there's actually a stop and so your
finger isn't on the trigger
it's on a piece of plastic oh when you
pull it forward it pulls the trigger
into your finger and then recoils back
oh so you just keep pulling the trigger
to you
you pull the gun forward and it pulls
the trigger hits your finger bounces
back you pull it forward it bounces back
so by pulling the gun forward and
putting that force it's going
interesting so they made those illegal
but bump fire as a technique which was a
lot
of people were complaining about like if
you if you want a bump fire you can just
do it if you know how to do it yeah you
can loop your thumb through your belt
loop
and then yeah uh wrap your finger around
the trigger and just sort of push
forward a little bit and it'll just
bump fire wow so that's why a lot of
super easy to do but
i think it's interesting because it's
not going to stop there especially with
3d printing
the the fgc 9 looks kind of crazy
compared to other guns you're used to
seeing
it's only a matter of time before
they'll keep trying to make rules and
eventually they're going to try and make
one all-encompassing rule and it won't
work
that's what i'm afraid of if the
government makes a law they can't
enforce
and become a total mockery of themselves
that's that's a real threat and then
what happens when people have no faith
in the system to enforce its own laws
i don't know man we're already at a
point where people really want to do
they get a 3d printer and make guns
hell yeah how hard was it back in the
day to make a gun you know like i'm
talking hundreds of years smith and
wesson
getting someone to actually make the
medal it took hundreds of years
to go from like muskets to cartridges
that's crazy and then think about how
long it's been
like the rapid development in weapons
technology over the past hundred years
it's kind of crazy
it's just just nuts yeah they used to
have like smith
like gun manufacturers were huge like
single companies and super popular smith
and wesson i don't really know i still
are
but but now there's just hundreds of
thousands of gun manufacturers i would
imagine i mean literally
if they're not people can make their own
guns right now everyone is a gunman
can you start a gun manufacturing
company uh with little oversight using
3d printers and then
i mean you could um there's
from the business perspective there's a
lot of hurdles to overcome like your
financial processing
is a problem with all the financial
censorship that's going on
yeah doesn't mastercard stop uh
didn't they release a statement that
they're not going to allow people to use
their credit cards at
gun stores uh i don't know if i can
actually follow
through with that or not i remember that
that was a big issue but what what are
some of the other financial restraints
well
even like you're you're considered the
obama
administration put forth operation
chokepoint which classified firearms
dealers as or anyone in the firearm
space is a high-risk business
and that added a whole bunch of
additional restrictions on who they
could do banking with and credit card
processing with
and it really limited so like none of
the major credit card processors will
work with you if you're a
business well most of them won't um
there are a very
very few but your your
you know your your service with them is
really limited based on you know the
political climate these days
um we just had so there's a company
that does uh crowdsource crowdfunding
like gofundme for
gun related projects called gun dynamics
their credit card processor
that canceled their contract with them
um i think
today i think this was today so it's
and just uh i i don't know what the
reason or any any background on that i
just heard that this happened
yeah i mean what what else can you do
cryptocurrency
the remarkable thing about
cryptocurrency is that it doesn't matter
which one you use
not even so the minds token do you know
what it's currently trading at
uh it's ranged between like
33 cents and a dollar 25 i think
you know what doesn't matter the value
of the token because i'll put it this
way
let's say this gun company gets their
credit card processor shut down so they
announced that uh
you know what we're going to use mines
tokens and then all that matters is
i can then buy mine's tokens the correct
value send it to them
then they can immediately transfer it
into u.s currency
through a regular market so it doesn't
matter what credit card company wants to
do there's a way to transfer the value
instantly mm-hmm
boom i was thinking
or like every time you pull the trigger
hold on it sounds like a joke now but in
50 years we'll
we'll look back on this every time you
pull the trigger it charges your account
no it writes the blockchain so you know
when the bullet was oh that's a good
idea
maybe it's a good idea it depends on
your if you want mass surveillance you
know
it depends on execution and and who has
access to that
it's an idea right yeah yeah
tracking when bullets are fired and
where well i don't know how you transfer
where they where they land
the gun has gps on it the bullets have
gps so now we're getting like those
smart guns
those depleting a whole another like the
depleted uranium bullets that are left
over in iraq are devastating they're
like in
the dirt irradiating people munitions
but you but you know where they were
shot you don't necessarily know where
they would go
like they can't put a gps in the bullet
you know what i mean well i don't know
who knows what crazy tech the military
is at this point for all we know you
know they got little
flies with cameras on them that fly
around there was a cool project 10 years
ago of these really tiny drones that
were like this big and they flew like
dragonflies
yeah it was cool that was 10 years ago
10 years ago okay it was like
eight years ago nano drones i mean they
weren't nano they were pretty big
they probably are now but they were
really lightning cameras on them and it
was
it was it was a kickstarter i think i
don't know whatever happened to that
project but there are tiny little flying
drones man they got them bug that keeps
dive bombing you yeah i know as you're
spying on us
i'm afraid of nano drones that'll fly in
people's ears and kill them
dare see that yeah black mirror where
the bees killed everybody
the robo bees good stuff it's the future
anyway yeah
i don't i wonder if we'll come to a
point where people start 3d printing
like like you can buy disposable guns
like disposable cameras like you walk
into the shop it's like i just need the
20 shot and it comes the magazine
pre-loaded
and it can't be reloaded it just it's
done when it's done and you throw in the
garbage because it's just like plastic
with a nail in it i'm most excited about
3d printing ammo
and i know you talked a little bit about
it or do you have any information
do you think you're going to have to
it's still it's still very much an alpha
sort of development like i said we're
still we're still working at the
chemistry to get smokeless powder
we're still working out like the the
actual construction of the round and
what kind of calibers you can use what
kind of pressures you can get
so there's a lot in development and
you know if you guys are in our are
chemists and you're you're interested in
in getting in this space this is
somewhere
you can make i heard you make you can
make bots out of bat poop
say what i heard you can make bullets
out of bat what about humans sure
no that's because bat has something
specific and it's called corona virus
but well
yeah yeah yeah something else like i was
reading like
how they would make black powder back in
the day yeah it doesn't have phosphorus
in it
is that it i don't know i think so i
don't know how to make gunpowder white
powder yeah
phosphorus yeah smokeless powder is the
is the better
yeah safer smokeless is what's in modern
cartridges
um black powder is what they used to use
what a lot of people still use for
certain types of hunting but uh it's
easier to make
so like the original bullets had tons of
smoke that would come out yeah uh it was
really just a lot smokier oh yeah they
transitioned because it if it got wet
it would they wouldn't fire well that
was more of a problem of
like having the whole yeah muzzle
loading in general where
everything was just exposed to the
elements um all the time
so a case can fire when they're soaked
right well everything can fire when it's
so
you can dunk an m4 in a pool and still
fire yeah in the bullets too the bolts
get wet they'll still fire yeah
because everything's encapsulated in
that cartridge so when you're printing
you can print the casing of the bullet
out of plastic
is that no not yet so we're not there
yet
um it's we're getting like abs because
like even straight up well like shotgun
shells are plastic
but they have the metal primer cap right
yeah so the shotgun shells is a
chemistry there there is a guy working
on
printable shotgun stuff it's the
liberator 12k project
um it's another cool one it's
an entirely or not entirely 3d printed
similar to the fgc 9 where you're using
off-the-shelf parts
but it's a 12-gauge that you can print
and it functions pretty well he's still
it's still in uh
in in beta he's doing a lot of he's been
testing it for like three years
he's going through on the test i was
watching that movie news of the world
and it's really interesting because
you know if you don't know the history
of guns but tom hanks's character has
birdshot
but he has brass shotgun shells that he
loads and he like pours the birdshot out
and then
spoiler alert if you haven't seen the
movie you've been warned there's a scene
where he's fighting with people
and all ace is birdshot he runs out of
bullets in his revolver
and then his little girl puts coins in
the brass shells and then he shoots and
kills a guy with
coins i think myth mythbusters did an
episode on that
yeah it didn't work very well well it
like i you know whether or not it would
work it was interesting this idea that
shotgun shells used to be
brass and reloadable basically yeah
that's crazy i mean now it's holy
polymers are still very new in like the
history of humanity
yeah so before polymers what did you
what kind of soft metal did you have
well you had
brass and well they start doing it they
start doing paper shells yeah
paper yeah because it just blows the
whole thing and sprays it out anyway so
they're working with like um recovering
plastic melting it back down in like an
anaerobic environment with no oxygen
back into like liquid
oil and then you could use that as a
printing filament
oh well and you can also grind up the
pellets and melt the pellets that way a
lot easier so
if you can start making ammo out of
recovered plastic and like scrap metal i
think that's the key
you need the primer obviously which i
don't know carbon i don't know if you
ever mess with graphene at all as a
i haven't but i'm i'm i'm not i'm
absolutely not the chemist like i have
no idea what's going on
it's magic to me if we could pull carbon
out of the carbon dioxide and make
help make primer out of that that'd be
interesting too yeah i'm really
spitballing here
well how about we go to super chats and
see what everybody else has to say if
you haven't already smash
that like button and go to timcast.com
become a member to help support the show
we're gonna have more bonus content for
all y'all coming up later tonight so uh
let's take your
your questions and comments david young
says excuse my lack of knowledge but
what's a grifter fence sitter and milk
toast
people keep calling you this but just
sound like silly kindergarten insults
okay
a grifter is someone who pretends to
have opinions in exchange for money
a fence sitter is someone who actually
has no strong opinions is sitting on the
fence
and milk toast means your opinions are
extremely weak i'm impressed that i can
be all three of those at the exact same
time
all right let's see dominic bristow says
i am also a gorilla indeed that's that's
wonderful and you might notice that the
iron gorilla shirt is now pinned above
the
i believe it's pinned on the chat so you
can you can buy that there yeah
let's see mao damai says you had me at
bumbum probe
love click bait it's not clickbait
though if people are like this is not
real
i saw people in chat saying it's not
real it's clickbait it's a real story
we didn't make up the headline they're
literally doing it
zinger says yo tim on permaban from
paypal do you plan on using any other
payment processors
check out coin payments if you haven't
heard of it i'd love to subscribe but
literally can't
um we we are uh
talking about setting up something just
like
off paypal i guess we'll we'll figure it
out the whole system itemguess.com is
relatively
new and we're just trying to build it
and make sure it works and then you know
grow but uh
we're gonna figure it out gerald
armstrong says tim talk to sargon to get
count dankel on adam's show
uh sure i've also been talking to sargon
and daniel to get him on this
show and covet makes it uh just very
very difficult to do
killer has family obligations too yeah
let's see 5882 300 says new member here
was hoping to help you or anyone in the
geodome quest with a shout out from my
buddy's company
thunderdomes we design and make custom
cheap domes hope you'll give us a look
p.s how did you not
finish the jingle which jingle i don't
know i don't know
i don't know um we're looking at doing
domes but man is it really hard to buy
land right now
and the longer it takes like man all the
rich people fleeing the big cities are
buying up land
like crazy which is kind of kind of kind
of a bummer man
stump says this is eerily similar to the
debut south park episode
moving my retirement portfolio to astro
glide
smart man people have been because i
tweeted the story people are sending me
a lot of south park images of poor
cartman
uh during that very famous south park
episode where he was that's right
probed by the english probe car goose
says rectum douche for victory against
the silent enemy
to quote emperor biden we need a
full-scale wartime effort
yes michael gilli says mr pool have you
or
have you or have you not in fact started
a polyamorous prepper cult also i'm a
gorilla
i have not unfortunately it's just not
the case so uh that won't be happening
giving me some ideas there omar says tim
as a canadian i'd love if you covered
some of the stuff happening up here
two weeks ago an ontario conservative
mpp was booted from the party for
writing a letter to the premier with
sources with suggestions to exit
lockdown
wow well you know it's the the great
reset
it is upon us the davos group is rather
successful in all of their their efforts
so you know good for them
fubadoo says hey control pew don't 3d
print guns explode in your hands
can't stop the signal do they explode in
your hands
they absolutely do
so they don't because people who are
only listening have no idea you held
your hands up
i forget there's like an audio component
yeah yeah
yeah he held up his hands his hands are
completely intact either that or i have
a really great prosthetic
break the chains media says now that
stixx hexenhammer is back in vermont you
need to get him an irl myself and
thousands of others would love to hear
you and sticks a banter and discuss
culture and society
look at my content too i would love to
have sticks on the show
we're working on it and smash that like
button if you haven't already
is greatly appreciated let's see we got
here
brent scigan says hey tim i fell behind
on a bunch of your videos
and to catch up i listen to them at two
times speed and hearing you all live
makes you sound drunk
uh well you can always go back and watch
these old episodes at two times speed as
well
yes i think the uh what we're doing now
for the members only content also has a
speed boost
too so now you should be able to watch
that in a lower resolution
and which makes it easier to stream as
well as increase the speed cool
ken l says your stream did not show up
on my subscription feed
had to go to tim cast irl page to see if
your stream was live i'm not surprised
but it was a first
i mean i am we put anal swab in the
title and i had a feeling youtube was
gonna be like
we don't promote that here and i was
like i don't care it's the story
we're doing it's important you know if
we did something like
i don't know just use buzzwords what do
you minecraft
what's the minecraft fortnight pewdiepie
democrat yeah bazong birthday
no if you put zombies you're gonna get
knocked down like anal swab
i don't know but like birthday and then
someone's name famous
marriage baby birthday yeah they did it
on twitter when you see this like
someone did something someone did on a
uh an experiment on facebook where they
would put
something like just got married or
something in all of their posts because
the algorithm would boost those words
because people interact with marriage
and childbirth
like congratulations so they would be
like i just you know gave birth to a
baby boy
anyway here's my new book it's coming
out yup
lua coder says tim i am now going out of
my way to buy things that are not
from china and i've realized how
difficult it is i refuse to support this
regime and i encourage everyone else to
do so
even if it sacrifices convenience i
completely agree
and we do try we need to try harder for
sure
payne cabal says get fps russia over to
talk guns with you
that'd be cool pirate tomsky says that's
why it's spreading tim the lefties have
been covering the wrong poophole the
whole time
oh jeez dozerman says keep an extra mask
in your disgusting pocket touch it cough
and sneeze in it and realize masks
aren't the most sanitary thing to touch
and reuse
it just shows you're in the cult well
look
there are disposable masks that are
super cheap i understand the purpose of
masks and i
really have no problem using it the
problem is the level of absurdity when
they're like now where to or
in china when they're like bend over
here it comes again you know
not really interested in all that let's
uh kargoosh says you misunderstand and
it's very important to understand this
they're not getting rid of the gifted
programs because of equality they're
getting rid of them because of a belief
in equity
that's right yep the black metal says
i'd be careful with making your own guns
last month atf rated polymer 80 because
of the idea of receivers having no
cereal
the biden admin is pushing hard on this
ghost gun thing
yeah that's what i was saying i think
their goal is to create obstructions and
hurdles to make it very difficult for
you to do and to scare the populace
yep ghost gun sounds scary right and
just like if they'll raid one
one p person it's like and then they
make stories about it like don't let you
be the next
be afraid don't do it king o jingling
says hi gang i'm raising awareness for
the farmer protest in india right now
we're trying to repeal three
agricultural laws that only benefit
corporations
the fight against corporate government
is the same worldwide love your work
i believe corporate government is
fascism yeah
the left likes to say it's not because
fascism is ultra nationalistic and i
feel like that's like a deviation
if if you know the goal of the nazis and
the fascists was like world domination
and taking everything over how is that
nationalistic when you're invading other
countries
you know what i mean also it's really
weird
that they keep saying fascist over and
over again with like an emphasis on
italy instead of nazis with an emphasis
on
hitler like they call people nazis for
sure but they really like saying
fascists over and over again
as if like italy was the prime problem
in world war ii they were one of the big
problems but
nazi germany was it i want to give a
shout out to the federal reserve because
i feel like it's
the most fascist thing in our country
right now it's like a corporation with
no
government oversight that's controlling
our government our monetary supply which
is
our kind of our government this is
interesting octorion says rand paul got
45 senators to kill the second
impeachment yeah oh good good which
means trump can run again if
it's if and trump can pour 72 million
dollars into
a bunch of political campaigns because
he repealed that uh
the lobbying thing yeah he's lobbying i
read an article about yesterday
well i think about it i think he wants
to run again so he's disavowing the
patriot party filings like people have
filed saying like their
joint fundraising's like that's not true
and apparently he told republicans he's
not going to start a new political party
i guess that's
that's probably the compromise he
probably went to them and said if you
convict me i will start a new political
party and get people to run against you
it'll be the end of the republicans
interesting which i think it would be a
great thing
i think people need to stop saying but
we have to have the republican party
there's a poll showing if people had a
choice between the patriot party
republicans democrats or other who would
they vote for
and republican and patriot are split
democrats have 46 percent but if you
combine republican with patriot party
it still loses to the democrats people
are not going to vote for republicans
next time around it's not going to
happen
there because there's because of
gerrymandering there's a possibility the
republicans reclaim the house that's
a you know play but i think without
trump a lot of people are walking away
that's why they they need trump trump
they
if they convict him it's all over for
the republicans but like i said even
then
you know in the presidential election
democrats would win
forrest horlacker says love the work
love you guys even ian sometimes
tim i disagree with your statement
lately to stop calling out the media
double standards
i think it's very important that we do
not give up and keep people in the know
it may seem redundant to you
uh looks like there's another one from
them coming up because it's got cut off
but i will just
say right now i'm not saying don't say
it i'm saying it's getting to the point
where we all
know and instead of saying oh no the
double standard we say
well there is a double standard and
everyone knows and it's not an issue of
like whether it is or isn't real
it is literally real so let's see i
think there may have been another super
chat but uh
i don't know where it is because it got
cut off but uh you know
vasht says gatling guns are not machine
guns
so you can legally own gatling guns
apparently i i'm not
i don't know all depends on your state
right yeah
yeah there you go i'm gonna investigate
that let's see where we're at
zanzibar says you can make an ar-15 full
auto
and i'm not going to read all of this
just in case but he says it is illegal
you should be uh yes you should be able
to have it whether yeah
so i can't i'm not going to read the
super chat that
mentioned something that's literally
illegal but apparently you can
they sell conversion kits for this stuff
too isn't it but it's like illegal like
the atf tries to get people to do it
yeah there's a lot of that funny
business going around don't do it
obey the law
zachary daly says hopefully you see this
uh hopefully you see this bought a
camera
i can make money from pretty much
anywhere looking to start broadcasting
recording these instances in the us
since youtube seems unsafe what would
you recommend
uh honestly i don't know youtube will
ban you if you're a journalist
so journalists independent journalists
are getting new to across the board
because
unfiltered content that just shows
things happening is a violation of
youtube's rules
i'm not even kidding be a good slave
work for cnn be promoted in the
algorithm be promoted in the search and
then five years later expose all the
horrible crap that they did
what you also use minds use multiple
platforms and start your own website and
host your content on your own website
too and then use
things like twitter and youtube to
promote it as long as you can
also library and odyssey for us anyway
they've been a great platform to host
content on like we put all of our files
up on there
all of our media goes up on there and
they're
they're they're one of the few platforms
that advertise us
as you know look the 3d printed gun
people are here they're super cool
i mirrored my entire youtube catalog on
library on odyssey
very cool why hasn't someone created a
social media platform that just
aggregates all the social media
platforms because you need all the
different apis no you don't you could
they could open as a browser
you could create an app that just
switches between the browsers and it's
logged in on each one
and it stores something switches between
the browsers so it could just function
like a browser okay so you build a
browser what does it do exactly
it holds four specific tabs for you know
or whatever social networks
and then you just swipe left and right
between all of them and it's just
functioning like a browser
so you'll have someone's youtube channel
you'll click their profile
and then it'll load up a browser with
all of their social media and you get
all of it in one feed because it
functions like a browser
if you wanted to get it in like one feed
the ap i think i understand but you
could literally just swipe left and
right on their different
posts to just go to their youtube
channel their facebook channel their
twitter channel
well so you just do that with brave well
they have to open all their channels
the idea is to create an app where you
can follow people but not control
banning them because you don't actually
host any content so here's the idea
they say parlor got banned because they
were hosting
violent content and refuse to take it
down okay here's what i'll do
i will create an app that allows people
to follow each other but you literally
can post nothing
you will never post anything we will
store nothing the only thing we get is
your name
and then if someone clicks your name you
as the person the only thing you can do
is include links to your other social
platforms
so if they come to us and say your app
is hosting us that's not true that's
twitter
that's not us all we do is a directory
for individuals in their social media
so like a portal kind of form but you'd
bet you'd be following them so
you you'd pull up your app and then
you'd you know you'd see the individuals
you'd see like all it would say is you
know you click the person
and then you'd see their twitter and
then you swipe you see their youtube you
swipe you see their instagram
and it functions like a browser that's
it it's just a browser
and it loads the website when you when
you click it then you'll be able to
follow everybody and they can't ban you
so what happens is let's say you're on
twitter instagram and youtube
and then i open my app and i'm following
ian crossland and i go to your name and
i see these three things
where you you post but then one day
you're banned from all of them
i still follow you but now you have no
active socials
so you go in and you change the link to
gab now when i click you i still see
your post oh i see but you're still
following me
so i don't lose my follow-up exactly you
lose no followers and who you're
following
and you can be banned a million times
and then eventually you just set up your
own website
and then when i click your name it just
loads your website in you know
superstar.com or whatever i like maybe i
shouldn't have given that idea away
don't do it maybe you should
just someone should build that well
maybe it's open source so people can
make more of them in case like an open
source directory that allows you to
follow anyone but doesn't post anything
so amazon can't we're going to say oh
you're hosting this content we're
literally not
it's literally just a browser where
someone has like linked to their
social accounts that's it i guess let me
ask you this do you think it would
matter
to amazon that you're not actually
hosting because it doesn't matter to
youtube
or google whether or not you violated
their terms they're still going to
delete your account
another thing to really kind of i saw a
new report
that came out that talked about how 95
94
of all child abuse images came from
facebook
you know when you have that in
comparison to parlor being taken down
that's a big difference there so to add
to that point that you were making
i think the idea would work i mean
obviously they would try to get rid of
it
and they would say it's a directory
listing a bunch of extremists or
whatever and i'd be like we don't host
anything at all all we do is it's a list
of people like
their names and then the content is from
somewhere entirely different
it's a browser it's a browser with
people who can make suggestions i guess
they can argue
people could put in links to like bad
sites or something yeah but you could
make it so that they could only link to
twitter
like they can only link to existing
social platforms or whatever but then i
could link to your
your twitter account with my browser
unless the apis
yeah so they would need the api to
verify that it's me
or it's just the wrong account and
they're telling you to follow somebody
else i guess hey you know it'd be really
fun if you block chained it
and that way everyone's hosting the
content on their own yeah they're
getting the whole blockchain
there we go yeah have you seen they
would still you know probably try and
remove the app from the app store or
whatever
and that's what people argued too like
when they were banning all these social
networks that's like dude what do you do
bana browser that's literally what they
did when they banned gab's fetiverse app
it was like banning a browser
what's this what was that app what's
that thing called fetiverse no no bro
uh gab made a browser extension i think
it's called oh dissenter yeah dissenter
where you can
comment on any website pocketnet is like
a decentralized blockchain
social network that that's pretty
promising yeah i like where that's
headed let's read some more super chats
geary vision says we weren't allowed to
use crew served weapons in many
populated areas of iraq and afghan
due to high numbers of civilian
casualties pelosi wanted to unleash them
on our own streets
effing disgraceful evil personified
joe walton says illinois has concealed
carry now but the licensing process
takes a very long time
it took my brother more than six months
to get his wow
or bribes jeez gareth green says
stability breeds complacency complacency
forget autocracy and democracy
enocracy for the win what's anocracy
anarchy well i don't know it's just
enocracy i feel like it's anarchy but
like
spelled fun martin edgar says california
has banned potato guns
okay that sounds right thomas bennett
says alex you can still officiate my
wedding buddy
from tridge yeah i am a uh i am uh
i am a pastor i can officially there you
go
and i did it for him and he never set up
a date so on you buddy
bridge spring bandersnatch says tim why
did it take you so
why did it take so long for you to gun
up you should have done it the day the
weirdo showed up at your house at 3am
then came back later
well we lived like literally next door
to the police station which is why when
the dude showed up the cops were there
in like less than a minute
and so i didn't think i needed cop told
me to buy a gun
he's like well here's what he said if it
were me i'd answer the door with a
shotgun
but looking at the laws i was like i'd
still have to run
so it's like someone comes to my door i
have to go out the back door and run
away
that's ridiculous it's just it's just
ridiculous so
maybe maybe take 10 steps and be like no
he's much faster than i am
sure but then you go to courtney and be
like we think you could have wow and
you're like but i couldn't doesn't
matter we think you could have
maybe rubber bullets i i think that
wasn't allowed either i'm not sure
it's crazy yeah but anyway look
ultimately covet happened and i was like
oh man
like we're we're gonna have to rely on
ourselves
it was just like i didn't think the
police would be able to handle mass
riots food riots
and we saw food riots we saw crazy stuff
happening not like the worst in the
world then we saw the george floyd riots
and then when the literal riots happened
with george floyd i was like i better go
get some guns
but i think i actually was in the
process of getting guns well before that
yeah you were
yeah it was like what shocked me was
when police station started shutting
down for covid
and there wasn't a mass well there was a
mass we're going to run out and buy guns
but there's more now than there was then
that surprises me
ag agca says pew is telling you guys the
hardcore mode
we're american and can use gun parts
like a glock or rp9 barrels for late uh
for
the latter being ten dollars i have no
engineering background and built in fgc9
it's like pc building cool
so i could just order those parts and
then do it yeah like we we covered
a little bit ago there are mods for the
fgc 9 let you use glock barrels or
and you can with a little bit of skill a
little bit of practice you can mod it
yourself
to use a different barrel that you
happen to have lying around
so you know the the options are there if
you want to use them
um the the fgc9 specifically was built
by a guy well it was a derivation of
another design
uh the the the fgc9 was done by a guy in
the uk
to specifically be you know something he
would be able to build
in the uk and you know by extension
through most of the rest of the world
that'd be fun to try and put one of
those things together yeah hard mode
absolutely
but russell brown says you can also find
ones with different attachments like a
cnc laser at your 3d printer
interesting stephen chamber says tim
please talk about video games more for
fun
we 90s kids need to stick together you
could cover game stories that wouldn't
be allowed today etc
i mean maybe on the website as we expand
that's the that's the plan we're going
to have a bunch of different kinds of
content there's going to be other
websites that start emerging from this
the goal with timcast.com isn't just to
be this podcast
but to actually expand and do more
different sites and and things like that
which
you will see soon in the meantime red
dead redemption two online is five
dollars on steam
till february get it wow or we could do
we could all play a video game as a
podcast we'd all play the last of us
oh yeah and that'll be the podcast
that'd be awesome there you go gemcast
says full auto is good when you're
outnumbered alone in close quarters
that's why government agencies don't
like it and wants to know who had them
even the odds
interesting j mac and cheese mcintosh
says tim love your work have you checked
out the battle between reddit and wall
street over gamestop stock
could be the could be the shot heard
around the world in the robin hood
investor revolution
i've been watching it i don't know
enough about it other than
basically some short sellers were trying
to like short
game stock game stop so then reddit was
like we're just gonna buy it
and then it screwed over hedge funds i
don't know the full story otherwise we
would have gone over so like a short
sellers when someone bets on
stocks like gambling on the the stock's
gonna fail and people saw all these big
corporations
gambling that the stock was going to
fail so they all invested in it raise
the stock and cause these corporations
to lose money
that's insane it's awesome gamestop i
but it doesn't mean that gamestop
stock is valuable they're just using it
to screw people over it but
some people are saying that if gamestop
switches to an online retailer they'll
own the market they should do that
and and they're slow and they're they're
missing the application behind steam and
origin and stadia which is microsoft
yep but they could they could still do
it they tried they tried shifting
so gamestop tried shifting into a more
like a geek culture thing with like geek
was
what's what's the store called uh the
geek something i don't know whatever
but uh i think what they should have
done is i should have opened up gaming
tables
like like brick and mortar gaming tables
yep board games and card games
and they already sell a lot of that
stuff i feel so bad with covet it's just
decimated that industry
definitely gareth green says tim the law
of scarcity is absolute
even if we had replicators there would
be a finite number of replicators not to
mention resources necessary to
manufacture them
replicators would make replicators and
the resource could be light
photons can be condensed into electrons
which can be
yes in star trek the uh i believe it's
the nacelles collect
hydrogen and then use that for their
replicators and then replicators can
replicate replicator parts to assemble a
new replicator
you can actually make light out of the
vacuum and then you can turn
light into matter i guess the general
idea is evidence
you do need the matter and they would
collect hydrogen
in massive amounts and then use that as
the base i was posting about how they're
actually creating light
out of the vacuum of space and then
they're turning the light into the
matter
so and then you can condense the
electrons into hydrogen well i don't
know
check this out you like this one bam
says have you started trying to develop
homemade ammo casings
apparently shot shells are made of hdpe
or ldpe plastic
full plastic shot shells were
experimented on during the 60s and 70s
by winchester
yeah that sounds awesome full plastic
yeah it's uh it's it's been worked on
there there's a guy who is actually 3d
printing the 12 gauge i talked about it
yeah
um uh
and i completely i got plastic shelves
yeah i've spaced on his username but
it's the liberator 12k project
uh it's 12 gauge plastic shotguns this
is interesting uh so i saw this video
aaron trucker says a gaming channel
called the spiffing brit made a video
explaining a youtube algorithm glitch
using community
polls he got over 25 million views in
two days it's going to be patched now
that it's public but you could benefit
now
i believe the spiffing brit is wrong i
believe he's absolutely wrong
so for those that aren't familiar what
he said was youtube rolled up the
community tab
function they wanted people to use it so
they created you know general algorithm
that promotes
those who post in the community tab but
because no one uses it you could now
make a post
put a bunch of keywords in it and then
youtube would send it to a ridiculous
amount of people he said that he was
able based on his calculations to get
around
25 million views well first i'll say i
could be wrong about this but my general
understanding is that he got
like 150 000 likes and then said if on
average four percent of people click
you know click the like button that
should be you know what we estimated
between 25 or so million or whatever he
said one in 40 people something like
that anyway
i think he's wrong about the algorithm
being a glitch it's not a glitch
and his discovery of it an exploitation
of it is exactly what youtube's wanted
the
entire time and i know this because
youtube's told me this
so you know uh this video comes out and
this guy's like
nobody uses it so if you use it you'll
get a ton of views
and it's like right that's what youtube
wants youtube wants people to use it and
get a benefit from it
so that people start using it now this
video comes out claiming it's an exploit
saying that youtube's not going to patch
this i don't believe they will
because the algorithm is designed to
work with an equilibrium
if only one person uses it then the only
community post anyone anywhere on the
site will see
is from one person if only 10 percent of
people use it
then everyone will see only 10 of people
who use it
now because of this video everyone
starts using it then it's going to
balance out and just normalize and
youtube needs to do
nothing so i've used the community tabs
frequently for a lot of things because
it's useful when it is but not for
you know enough seeing that video just
made me go
oh yeah i should post more on the
community tab not like wow what an
exploit no i fully get it
youtube emailed me a long time ago
saying we're going to be prioritizing
the community tab
and those that use it more will see a
higher watch time and we'll see
you know all these benefits and i was
like cool right on that was it
it's not a secret youtube's been telling
creators to do this they've been
emailing them telling them to do this
it just so happened that nobody cared
and some dude discovered that he can get
a ton of views because nobody cared
and then he told everybody i guess and
now he's going to get a lot of play for
it good for him
i just think it's what youtube wants
they're happy it's happening
but uh you can give it a shot if you
want it will benefit you because nobody
nobody uses it right
caitlyn shaw indie game says the real
question for tonight's guest will
biden buy back a 3d printed 3d printed
gun and how much profit margin is
control p looking at here
will he is that is when they do gun
buybacks is there any
uh like restriction on what you can turn
in i mean i feel like
the more terrifying that they tell you
the firearm is
the more money they should give you for
it so
if on average i spend two dollars per
printed firearm and you know i have a
lot of
r d so there's a lot of failed prints
that are close enough to being firearms
where i think they're firearms and these
people at the buyback aren't gonna know
the difference
so i feel like i'm looking at a margin
of like
four to five hundred dollars per and i
have a box full
so anyone who comes to this buy back
after me isn't going to get anything
because i'm
just going to take all their money well
there you go excellent plan
bud snack says have you seen the recent
rage against the machine propaganda
piece
i know they are left but did not believe
they would go that far i didn't see it
has anybody seen that no
what did they do i don't know and uh
someone messaged me about it i'll read
it really quick
hank mccormick says ask your guest about
his opinions about polymer 80 and 80
lowers i think we did yeah i think we
talked about with the the buy-back
the the buy build shoot kit i think the
atf is wrong
and i think polymer 80 does good work
let's see placid saint says hey tim the
ammo company phoenix here in michigan
got cited for its employees not wearing
masks and now they're no longer selling
distributing ammo to law enforcement or
their departments
wow that's funny spicy there you go
heart you phoenix
there you go griffin game says all this
talk about pew pews reminds me of a
quote about calibers
quote nine millimeter takes care of the
body 45 takes care of the soul
don't want people coming back as a lich
what's that from
well you said something about liches
what like a video game yeah it was a
quote about
45s not wanting because they don't be
able to come back as a lich it sounds
like arfcom lore to me
are they trying to shatter their uh
their uh
what is it called they're uh phylactery
i don't know if you destroy the liches
phylactery they can't respond it
is sterling morris says tim look up
trigger activators they allow
essentially full auto fire by means of a
hand crank that attaches to the trigger
guard
and are legal similarly crank gatling
guns are perfectly legal and considered
semi auto
so the crank attachment
is not legal in the state of iowa oh
federally
yeah you're probably okay what does it
do
it hits the trigger when you break it
it's got a little flap on a little on an
axle and as you crank it it just pulls
the trigger so how do you hold it do you
like so like your shoulder
and then you just like that wow oh my
gosh see how
like you can't regulate it all
everything eventually someone's gonna
figure out some weird ridiculous
circuitous system that uses a loophole
yeah
someone like i was saying it's gonna get
rid of someone have an accordion and
they're like i'm just playing music
this is why prohibition never worked
your government doesn't work
this is uh government doesn't work it's
all gone the rage against the machine
they're doing a documentary on race
and racism called killing in my name
it's a 15-minute mini dock i haven't
seen it though here's in that video of
the people with the trump flags and like
the blue lives matter flag dancing to
killing in the name of
or is it killing in the name it's kind
of funny because the song is literally
about cops killing
you know non-white people and there's a
trump supporter with like a blue
thin blue line flag and they're like
singing the song and dancing and then
they were
i think um tom morello he said when we
wrote the song we never imagined
like this would happen you know well i
maybe they don't understand
uh conservatives enough i had many
interesting conversations with tom
morello and he always seemed like
someone who didn't like the left and the
right but i guess that's
changing now money talks bs walks
tiger says there are over 100 million
ak-47s on earth if 99 of them magically
vanished it leaves one per day for the
next 2
739 years there will never be an be a
world without guns they're too easy to
make
google dara adam kell pakistan
interesting
william sammitt says tim pool gives
horrible advice he tells people to
smash that like button but i am a
gorilla and now my computer is broken
give it a little little tap just a
little teeny terry
headbutt joshua insert says potassium
nitrate check out dr stone yes
ah is that what's in the back yeah
that's better there you go
gunny uh arl arliquin are we talking
about metal printing for cases
or one use plastic i'm guessing the 55
000 psi of a 556 was not would not agree
with plastic
yeah probably um single-use plastics for
a lot of like lower pressure black
powder stuff 12-gauge stuff shotguns can
probably get away with it
uh for rifles we're going to need some
sort of casting to get involved and
if we're going to use the fdm space
all right abrasive fpv says i received
my type 07 ffl a few weeks ago
currently tooling up to start selling
extremely affordable 3d printed guns
control pew and ivan have been an
inspiration for me the mission is to
legally arm as many people as possible
for as little as possible
interesting a store that sells 3d
printed guns they'd be really cheap
wouldn't they
i would imagine uh until you get
insurance involved it's like i was it's
like i was saying
you like like kodak disposable cameras
you know you don't need a camera you go
and you buy the disposable one it's got
the film you can't reload it
you bring it in they break it open get
the film out that's it you buy
the 3d printed gun and once the
magazine's in it's a 20
it's got 20 rounds that can't be
reloaded like a disposable camera
i wonder if you could brace plastic
bullets like with metal so
like instead of printing the whole case
out of metal you print it out of plastic
and then you cap it with a little bit of
metal so that when
the pressure when it hits pressure it
doesn't shatter like if the metal could
somehow
somehow break so you don't have to you
just say i don't know
how does the so the the liberator is
pure plastic with a nail right
yes so that plastic can withstand the
the pressure of the nine millimeter
obviously for
the amount of rounds so the liberator is
using either a 38 acp or 32 which are
pretty low power low power pistol
cartridges
and the barrel is very thick could you
do 22
i know it's a rimfire but would you be
able to do it i have seen it done
i don't know like the longevity of that
yeah
because i'd imagine it's much weaker
it's not so
it deals with chamber pressures that
initial shock uh
is what creates the fracture and then
destroys the barrel interesting so
it's a little higher than the others but
oh okay so it's worse
yeah oh wow well the more you learn you
know
there you go all right let's grab a
couple more of these
kami sama says flamethrowers are not
legally weapons in michigan long live
the murder cube
they're legal almost everywhere except
for two states that's irritating
jose gonzalez says tulsi gabbard was on
tucker carlson an hour ago and she's def
she and she'd definitely be an awesome
republican candidate isn't that funny
yeah
yeah she really she released a very
powerful video today comparing john
brennan to
and adam and adam shift to trying to
institute
kgb tactics here in the united states
she said surveillance state
she said they're a bigger threat and
more dangerous than those who stormed
the capital
she said the john brennans and the adam
schiff's who want to institute a kgb
police state in this country tulsi
gabbard
just started a local's account that's
dave rubin's social network there you go
she's she's going social there you go
janet partridge has tim just wanted to
thank you i used to paint realism
paintings and oils i haven't done a
painting in five years
thanks to him getting back into it i
just wanted to know your messages do get
through appreciate it
awesome well if you haven't already go
to timcast.com and become a member
because we will have bonus segments
more bonus segments and uh next week we
are going on a special top secret
mission which we will film much of
and create a special members only video
which may involve
something that rhymes with
schmidty g and
re did that did that work no
no no no you confused a whole bunch of
people you sound like q anon
okay let me try again it's um
it uh rhymes with schmifty malibur
okay there you go that worked right yeah
yeah we're gonna make a video hopefully
hopefully
and we're going out uh special mission
and uh that that may be the plan
so i'm hoping that's how it works out
but it'll be for members only
and we will be back uh of course live
tomorrow night
you can follow me on twitter instagram
parlor at i'm sorry not parlor wow why
did i say parlor
parlor will be back yes twitter
instagram minds
at tim cast i i do have a gab account i
don't i've never posted there
but uh you know i'm gab at tim cass as
well and uh like i said temcast.com
become a member alex do you want to
shout out your social media your
projects where people can download your
guides to learn about 3d printed guns
yeah so first place you go
theguide.controlpew.com that'll get you
started
in 3d printing uh controlp.com is my
site we'll post updates about what's
going on with community new file
releases news and events
and finally all of my social medias i am
control pew
if you click the little menu on the side
of my site you'll get
all of them i'm everywhere right on
i live by a very simple model if the
government exists
you have to watch out for your
sphincters a very simple
common uh you know information that i
share on my youtube channel we are
changed the shirt that i'm wearing right
now says thinking is extremely dangerous
to our democracy you can get it at
thebestpoliticos.com and i
thank you guys for watching and
participating in this show
you guys are really freaking cool and
thanks for giving me the opportunity to
talk to everyone
you guys are really freaking cool man
right um you said it's it's guides
uh slash c t r l p
uh the guy dot control p so ctrl pew.com
got it hey i want to give a special
thanks to tim
poole for purchasing me this graphene
for christmas this is pure graphene
cool i knew it was the perfect gift yeah
it really is and i'm gonna be spinning
this in a moment but alex i'll show this
to you in a bit because when you were
talking about making black powder this
stuff is black powder
so i wonder if it's pure carbon so i
wonder if this will somehow be a future
ammo i just want to give a shout out to
graphene spin it for you
and um you can follow me at ian
crossland
i'm going to be i believe we're going to
be gaming later tonight on twitch.tv
ian crossland so come follow me there
follow me on twitter and i'll shout you
out on twitter when i'm about to go live
super cool and then me in the corner i
looked up anocracy
since somebody mentioned it in the super
chat and apparently it is really a thing
it's a form of government that is
loosely defined as part
democratic and part dictatorship or as a
regime that mixes democracy with
autocratic features so that's kind of
interesting
interesting today i learned okay so i
finally figured out my socials
so on instagram and gab i am at real
sour patch lids
and on twitter and mines i am just sour
patch lids so you can follow me at any
of those places
and of course we'll be back live like i
mentioned and you can check out my other
youtube channels youtube.comtimcast
youtube.comcastnews the goal of what
we're doing with timcast.com is going to
be more than just
this show it's going to be eventually
more more personalities
it's going to be a bigger brand it's
going to be a bunch of stuff and and
you'll see don't worry don't worry
it's it's coming and um there's a lot i
can't necessarily talk about now but
we're gonna take care of everybody and
make sure everybody is uh um
who wants to be a part of it can be so
trust me in that one other than that
stick around because we'll have some
bonus content coming up at timcast.com
for members only
and we will see you then later today
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you
next time or whatever later guys bye
guys
you